[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
is the Tony Michaels podcast real and
raw political and social commentary the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty you [__] eating
[__] ah the smell of freedom of speech
this is the Tony Michaels podcast and
this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
oh to be a fly on Mike Pence's head
during the questioning
of the special counsel
oh let me let me let me uh address
something here very quickly well not
quickly you know me we're gonna take the
first 30 minutes probably
it's the a block and it's Friday you
know what Friday is bonehead of the week
bonehead of the week in the second hour
of the Tony Michaels podcast you are
watching live on YouTube Twitter and
twitch simulcasting from the Midas touch
Facebook page also from my Facebook page
at the Tony Michaels go to
thetonymichaels.com to find all the
links where we air live every single
weekday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific
and also think about
um just think about it just go over and
take a look at the patreon we have
several new patreons we're reaching our
goal of a hundred patrons 100 supporters
in our new [__] fam community
over on patreon so if you want to be
part of the [__] fam
over on patreon just go to the
tonymichaels.com the link is at the top
of the page to check out patreon there's
additional content that I do other than
the show I will never gate the show the
show will always be free to you airing
live and also free to download
at all two hours and I'd like to do
three hours I'd love to get the three
hours
and you can make that possible by going
to the Tony michaels.com and checking
out the patreon page so here's what I do
over there I do additional content I'm
gonna do something this weekend not sure
exactly how to do a rant course but
it'll be extended rant about something
that I think is going to work its way
out of the news cycle
I kind of have an idea to be quite
honest with you a story that is
happening in my home state of Missouri
that I was just reading about before I
came on the air so I think that's what
we'll talk about on patreon this weekend
uh in the additional content of course
you get me live for free
absolutely 100 free
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central for two
full hours Ted a again is Friday so it's
bonehead of the week
where you vote you decide for the
bonehead of the week and me and my
co-host Gabe Sanchez break it down in
the second hour of the show
oh boy
let's start with the top story I think
is the top story really I mean yesterday
there was more [__] [__] committees
you know and yesterday they were talking
about the weaponization of the federal
government and what they mean is please
do not criminally charge us oh someone
brought up in the chat
someone brought this up in the chat
before I go too much further
Angus here on uh Agnes here on uh
YouTube says congratulations on 14
000. we did we reached 14 000
subscribers on YouTube
yesterday so thank you very much to
everyone who subscribed and if you're
not go ahead and subscribe right now
even if you're on another platform
please come over and subscribe to the
Tony Michaels YouTube channel
on the road to 20 000 I think once we
hit 20 it's gonna be really fast after
that
whatever YouTube's a [__] there
are my and if they're listening and
you're gonna cut this episode because I
called you a [__] do it YouTube
is a [__]
they just
it's just more censorship than a
Republican party to be quite honest with
you but you know that's how it goes it's
their platform they are welcome to
censor me it's what I gotta live with
what the [__] am I gonna do it's not
mine I don't own Twitter I don't own
YouTube I don't own them I can't help it
but if you'll help me out getting as
many subscribers as we can to let
YouTube know that there's plenty of
people that want to watch this show
rather they'll take the episodes down or
not or ban I don't know who who knows
we'll see what we'll see how it goes
we'll see how it goes but thank you for
14 000 thank you very very much
that is all thanks to you the listeners
and the Watchers and supporters for
sharing the link to the YouTube channel
and getting more subscribers and
bringing a larger audience
we've had we've had great audience
attendance on the live show we've had
great views after the live show on
replays
fantastic we've had great downloads and
you can download every episode in the
afternoon after I get it uploaded after
we're done recording on Apple Spotify
Google so thanks for your support there
as well
so Mike Pence
Mike Pence is he flipping well I believe
that it's not flipping
I believe that Mike Pence is gonna go
tell the [__] truth that's why over
the last several months him and his
attorneys have been negotiating with the
special counsel
now a lot of people want to surmise that
this is the last step before they get to
Trump the only thing that I'm for sure
of
with the negotiation between Mike
Pence's attorneys and him to be
subpoenaed and to go testify
is this Mike Pence is not the target
okay that's very important that's very
important when we're talking about the
special counsel because this special
counsel is not just designed to
prosecute trump it is to prosecute
anyone who is involved in the Cheeto
dust
kangaroo coo scheme right
if they broke Federal statutes now
we know from the January 6 select
committee hearings that Mike Pence and
his legal staff when he was the vice
president of the United States looked at
all avenues to try to find a legal
justification to overturn our vote in
the 2020 election they looked at all
avenues they actually explored this we
we found this out in the January 6th
select hearing when Mike Pence's Eagle
staff the vice president the office of
the vice president's legal counsel gave
testimony they were considering that
this might be a legal option and the
legal option was is to send it back to
the States I'll do the Don Jr thing
walking through the forest that is the
that is what the legal that is what John
Eastman Donald Trump
and the seditious allies that were
trying to overturn our vote were trying
to get him to do and that was the
language to turn it over to the states
well I actually think that they were
trying to convince Mike Pence to do
something much broader and much more
criminal and much more seditious which
was to accept fake electors on the floor
because what would happen if Mike Pence
turned this over to the state's quote
unquote and then all of a sudden oh yeah
out of nowhere look we got new electors
these electors just showed up we don't
have to have the state to reboat and
send it back to the states which has
been done before in our country's
history it's just been a long
[__] time folks
foreign
so I believe that is the aim of Jack
Smith's
um questioning not only Mike Pence Mike
Pence's legal staff the vice president's
legal staff because you gotta remember
it was legal counsel for the office of
the vice president
they were giving government
in the way of Mike Pence as vice
president now former vice president
legal counsel to what he could and
couldn't do constitutionally
and they were looking for ways to do
this we we know that Mike Pete's Pence
even called Dan Quayle
and Dan Quayle of all people can't spell
potato but he may he may have talked
some sense into Mike Pence to not break
federal crimes because Trump and his
allies were pressuring him to do so
we know that from the January 6 select
hearings we don't need to guess this
stuff this this idea that somehow we
don't know why Jack Smith is going to
question Mike Pence's [__]
bone-headed and to not know that this is
not the last step to Trump but the
obvious
glaring thing that comes out of the news
of Jack Smith's subpoenaing Mike Pence
and Mike Pence negotiating for months
now I'm no [__] lawyer but to me it
sends the signal that Jack Smith
's Target is not Mike Pence
which only lays the target Square to the
people who were trying to pressure him
which we know from the January 6 select
hearings Donald Trump was pressuring
Mike Pence
that's why his supporters were calling
for him to be hanged on the day of
January 6 when Mike Pence wouldn't do
what he wanted him to do he was a [__]
as Donald Trump said don't be a [__]
of course they're all pussy-ass [__]
we went over this yesterday p-a-b [__]
ass [__] Mike Pence is a [__] ass
[__] I can't even believe
that in in 2020 after that election and
really the lead up to January 6 and 20
early 2021 that Mike Pence and his legal
counsel were even considering this
nonsense they were even trying to find a
way that they may be able to appease the
little man child
[__] ridiculous it's crazy is it
criminal I don't know I don't think Jack
Smith believes that Mike Pence has
committed crimes but Mike Pence
definitely wants to negotiate
this subpoena in a way that does not put
him at risk for liability of criminal
activity
it would really hamper him to run as
president in a primary and lose
Mike Pence will never be the Republican
nominee folks in Gary everything you can
guarantee about anything anywhere Mike
Pence will never be the Republican
nominee for president of the United
States
nope no how no way just won't be ah
[__] Mark it down someone take a time
stamp Tony Michael said on February 10th
Friday at 12 12 p.m eastern time that
Mike Pence will never ever never ever be
the nominee for president United States
of the Republican Party mark it the [__]
down he won't be maybe the fly the fly
probably could be but not Mike Pence but
who wants to be that fly on the on Mike
Pence's head as he gives his testimony
because I think the aim of the testimony
is going to be to this state elector
scheme
I think that is where Jack Smith's
target for his prosecution is
is the state elector's scheme where they
fraudulently were trying to submit State
electors that was the whole purpose of
John Eastman's memo and the whole
purpose of John Eastman saying that Mike
Pence needs to stall and give it back to
the quote States
while these seditious Republicans these
Rio America First Nazis were waiting in
the wings with fraudulent electors to
present Mike Pence on the floor
that was the scheme
and then after it didn't happen the
fraudulent scheme of Trump trying to
grift his supporters and fraudulently
taking money from them to pay for legal
bills in which he did not pay uh is the
other thing I think Jack Smith
is investigating
and also the cover-up which is the
documents
that were stolen from us
which is to cover up the attempt of the
Cheeto dust kangaroo coup and the state
elector scheme and the fraud in which
Donald Trump stole fraudulently his
supporters money for legal funds in
which he did not pay
that's it and it says I mean what else
what else do you want Jack Smith to
investigate I mean he's going to uncover
a lot of rock there's there's going to
be state legislators State officials
that are going to be federally indicted
on the state elector scheme
um John Eastman Jeffrey Clark who were
heavily involved there's going to be
congressmen I don't know if you heard
this story there's been a lot of news
but Scott Perry you know this you know
this treasonous piece of [__] is he's a
congressman sitting Congressman oh man
he's been rewarded for his treasonous
behavior
by that [__] coward Kevin McCarthy
but Scott Perry over the last several
months is trying to negotiate with the
Department of Justice not to get the
contents of his cell phone listen this
is the same stupid [__] of if you if you
don't have anything to hide what the
hell is the problem
what the hell is the problem Scott Perry
if you don't have anything to hide about
January 6 and you trying to steal our
election away from us the voters then
why why are you working so [__] hard
if there's nothing if there's nothing to
hide there is something to hide they
know they did this that's why they were
asking for [__] pardons people
it's not complicated to understand these
things we we went into January 6 select
committee hearings and making a and b
dot to dot is not difficult
but it is difficult in a court of law
they have to approved they have to have
evidence I mean they have to present a
grand jury to get charges of indictment
an indictment with charges excuse me
that's it is a it is a tougher bar to
reach than just known information
it's a tough for bar to reach and I
believe that Jack Smith in subpoena Mike
Pence and finally getting that subpoena
negotiated is a key indicator and number
one Mike Pence is not the target of this
investigation
which is significant
that's significant meaning it Narrows
the scope of who is the target if you
really think about it right if you boil
it down to who's being subpoenaed
because
ultimately most of the folks that Jack
Smith is going to charge are never going
to be subpoenaed they're not going to be
subpoenaed to come in and give testimony
to the grand jury
they're the target they're the one being
[__] indicted
and
people being charged with indictments
aren't normally hauled in to talk in
front of the grand jury it just doesn't
happen that often to defend yourself
from indictment you're usually defending
yourself from from charges
and a guilty charge or a juror a guilty
jury
that would bring a guilty verdict
that's what you're normally fighting
against
so this that's one significance I see of
it
the other significance I see is the
point that most legal and analysts are
making is that they're getting closer to
Trump I mean you don't get much closer
to Trump than Trump's standing on the
ellipse telling his [__] supporters
if Mike Pence doesn't do this and he's a
bad person we gotta get him and then
they went to the camp like hang my pants
he didn't do what Trump wanted him to do
he's not his friend anymore and he's not
our friend
I mean you don't get much more closer
to the act of sedition than that
my opinion I mean that's the whole
reason why Stuart Rhodes and The Oath
Keepers
that were were found guilty
because they were waiting for the
president of the United States to
declare martial law through the
Insurrection act so they could take over
the government
just like this scheme of Mike Pence and
the state electors again two different
[__] things
Donald Trump wanted to make sure that he
had as many ways to overturn the
government become dictator as possible I
mean when you're when you're trying to
plan a coup of a government especially a
government
as such of the United States of America
you definitely don't want to just have
one plan you want to have a few
contingencies in place I mean you know
anyone would know this
even a buffoon would know and if you're
going to overturn a government and
commit a coup and become the dictator of
of a democracy like the United States of
America you're gonna have a couple of
contingencies in place right you want to
make sure to have plan a plan B plan C
maybe Plan D
and that's what they were doing
and I believe Jack Smith is going to
bring all them into Focus to one plan
which was one person wanting to remain
the president United States come hell or
high water no matter what even if he has
to steal it
and that's
and that folks is the story and the
legacy of Maga
and the reason why some of the stuff
you're seeing in these committees is so
ridiculous so laughable
so [__] bone-headed it's unbelievable
that they're even saying this stuff out
loud and putting themselves in their
disposition but is it
is it really
I mean what principles do they still
stand for they they tried to overturn
our democracy
and these [__] are still
operating in our government and they
have control over one half of our
legislator
sorta
kinda I mean
it's obviously no one has control over
there at all like at all they're just
[__] flinging [__] everywhere
it's great it's hilarious
and I know I know it it's making a
mockery of our Institution
but folks we must make a mockery of them
and show the American people that this
is why you don't put non-serious people
in charge this is why you don't put
people who fundamentally don't want
democracy in charge of our democracy
it's not really that complicated
I mean it it's not
rocket surgery if you want if you want
to give it a a good phrase
yeah I know brain surgery rocket science
I combined them rocket surgery I mean
you would think that that would come out
of Lauren bobert's mouth right well it's
not rocket surgery
oh but on they go with the [__]
committees and on they go with the lies
not surprising why wouldn't they why
wouldn't they
but the truth shall be known
because we have a negotiated subpoena
from Mike Pence Mike Pence knows he
cannot lie
he cannot lie
you go to a special counsel you better
have your [__] together
you better have your story buttoned up
especially if there's any chance at all
at all any chance that you may have
criminal liability
because the last place Mike Pence wants
to be besides in a room alone with a
woman is a federal prison
I mean it's like
in a room alone with a woman because he
doesn't trust himself and then a federal
prison probably
you know he's not allowed to be in a
room alone with a woman he just can't
trust himself he may do something crazy
isn't that kind of weird
and that kind of weird that we voted in
a vice president that doesn't trust
himself and his wife doesn't trust him
enough to be alone in a room with
someone of the opposite sex in that
little [__] strange
this is 2023. and we're electing people
who can't trust themselves or their
their spouse can't trust them to be in a
room with someone more than
a man at all
at all
like if Mike Pence walked in a room and
there's just a woman in there he's got
he's got a duck-tailed run he can't be
in that room not more than one two
seconds
can't trust himself
I mean Jesus Christ and we trust this
person to be the vice president of the
United States are you kidding me
how do how did we miss that
how did this country miss that we put a
guy who definitely assaults women by
grabbing them by the [__] admittedly
on camera and on a hot mic
and then the guy who's running with him
can't be trusted to be in a room with a
woman
how in the [__] did we get to this spot
and there's an entire cult built around
the one who's admittedly like yeah [__]
not only will I not be in a room with a
woman I won't be in a room with a woman
where I can't grab her because they let
me people like me do [__] like that
can you believe that
remember remember what what this country
the the the the absolute nonsense
that went on
with uh Michelle Obama's the size of her
arms remember that
oh my God
Michelle Obama's got to be a man as if
that makes a difference in the world
but the size of her arms you remember
this they still talk about that [__]
today today they still talk about this
stuff
and there's so much garbage so much of a
trash heap of a [__] trumpster fire
that we can't even remember that the two
[__]
that were that were trying or not trying
depending on if your Pence of The Fly
overturn our government and and and the
person who sexually assaulted dozens of
women and admittedly said I grab them by
the genitalia because I can
foreign
our government but we put them in a
position to do that
and they bitched about Michelle Obama's
arm side still do
as if that has anything to do with
politics I don't know what it looks like
I mean it looks like Michelle Obama
works out to me
I mean
tells Ron with lift in a few weights
nothing wrong with that
that's the way a person wants to
exercise all I'm saying is isn't this a
little [__] nuts that the people who
are yelling and screaming about not
being able to see Hunter Biden's [__] on
Twitter
and Michelle Obama's arms and Barack
Obama's tan suit are the same
[__] who completely ignore
that Donald Trump
grabs women by the [__] when he's alone
with him and really out in public but
Mike Pence can't be in her own with a
woman because he doesn't trust himself
because maybe he'll do that I don't know
it's kind of [__] weird
that here we are 2023
that far away from 2016
and we put ourselves in this position
because folks that's truly what happened
we put ourselves in this position
because we did not engage in democracy
we're getting there oh we're getting
better at it we're getting much better
at it
way better at engaging in democracy
but not enough to drown out their
[__]
they have a lot of microphones and
they're really [__] loud I don't know
if you noticed it
these megalodites are [__] loud
they're horribly loud and they don't
shut the [__] up
ever holy [__] they don't shut the [__]
up
I mean have you been watching some of
these clips from the committee hearings
I mean we're gonna show some more today
I'm sure and the shitless Roundup and in
the bonehead of the week
because we have a few a few of these
people on the [__] committee
and the bone end of the week and and we
have someone who testified in front of
the [__] committees Jesus Christ these
people just
whoosh but they're the loudest the most
annoying and it's terribly loud
that's why I do what I do every day two
hours a day is yelling scream to try to
combat it right I mean this is the war
we fight information
we're not in a hot War we're not in a
hot Civil War we are in a civil war of
information
and they like to lie I don't know if you
noted they lie a lot
they have they have no they have they
don't give a [__] either oh they'll
[__] lie
I mean how do you think they get elected
I mean they're really pissed off about
George Santos about the stupid lies he's
told but every single Republican who is
elected to congress every [__] one of
them there isn't a there is not quote me
there is not a republican congressman
elected to this 118th Congress Congress
that did not get elected without lying
to their constituents
the people who voted for him they had to
lie to him to get elected no [__] way
I mean if they told the truth there
wouldn't be a republican elected
anywhere
I mean think about it
where else would they get elected that's
that's one of the videos I plan on doing
this weekend on the patreon is here in
the state of Missouri every single
[__] legislative every single House
of Representatives member in the
Republican caucus in Missouri the
Missouri legislator the Missouri
legislator is very similar
to the federal legislature you have
state senators and state house reps
and every single [__] state house rep
voted
for school-aged children to carry
in schools and on the streets why not
why why not why not why not have
six-year-olds running around fully armed
with AR-15s I mean you know what your
community feels safer when you have a
bunch of kids running around with
Firearms especially semi-automatic
Firearms it's a god-given red I'm not
[__] you that's real I'm gonna go
over it this weekend
that is and I don't because I don't have
time today we got bonehead a week but
that is a real [__] thing that is
happening in these states
and it's every [__] one of them
voting for this crazy [__]
that defies logic and reasoning
that would baffle any [__] person
that has a reasonable standpoint on our
society and safety
baffle them but they don't know because
they're like well I'm a republican
because my daddy vote Republican do you
know what your representative's name is
well no I just marked the r cause my
daddy did
do you know what they vote for what no
I just vote for Republicans because my
daddy and my granddaddy it's a really
stupid [__] but that's how most people
vote is affiliation
well the church tells me that I should
pray and then vote Republican
yeah the church tells you you should
pray and vote Republicans so they do
because it's affiliation
and they don't want to be an outcast how
would you like to stand in a group of
[__] knuckleheads
telling you how much they love
Republicans and then you're like well I
actually voted for the Democrat that's
the other reason
is third party endorsement
by peer pressure
it's fairly simple it's not complicated
that's how it works
they have
cornered the market on stupidity the
Republican party they have and that's
the affiliation folks and they don't
give a [__]
they don't care
but we have to keep going we have to out
loud them
we have to be louder than those punk ass
[__] on the right because they are
snowflakes they are punk ass [__] as
we went over yesterday
I'm glad to have you here every single
weekday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific Live on YouTube Twitter and
twitch don't go anywhere
we're gonna come back with a shitless
Roundup and then bonehead of the week at
the top of the other hour
stay tuned
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
breaking news
[Music]
FBI Church
um this is not
um it's not out of the ordinary if this
is what is happening let me see if I can
find some breaking news here on the um
on the Pence case I just have to do with
the documents is that what they're
saying I think some people are saying in
the chat or something do you do how
about a part and blanket for Pence oh
baby you know what I actually believe I
believe
this this talk that Biden would pardon
some of these people for the sake of the
country I believe that that is one of
the pardons
that Joe Biden would consider
I I don't think he should I don't think
he should pardon Pence if that were the
case
if there is to be criminal activity
right you know what I mean
like if he goes and he testifies in
front of the grand jury and Jack Smith's
like whoa whoa wait a second that
doesn't match up with the evidence I I
think I think that Joe Biden would
consider pardoning pen not Trump and
probably not Eastman and not Giuliani I
don't know I don't think he would give
those considerations I think he would
give Mike Pence consideration and the
only reason why I say he would give it
consideration the only reason why I say
that the only reason why I say that
is because of the testimony that we that
we witnessed on January 6th the select
committee even though that it is
Despicable that Mike Pence and his legal
counsel would seek out a way to give
Trump what he wanted they ultimately
pushed back push back push back on these
really stupid [__] ideas
so one could argue one could argue that
they they were only exploring these
options to explain how [__] stupid
and how seditious and boneheaded it was
that these were even ideas one could
make that argument I know I don't know
if that's a good argument to make or not
for Mike Pence but in these in if you
were seeking a pardon
on
former vice president Mike Pence's
behalf that is the argument that you
would probably make to Joe Biden the
president of the United States if there
were criminal charges brought against
Mike Pence now again I think it's
depending on those
those
um
there's charges but Amanda's right here
man is right no no buy thinking of
Pardon no none of these [__]
he ain't gonna pardon nobody but again
if he was going to consider gonna
consider it I think Biden being the
decent human being that he is and the
decent man that he is he would at least
give Mike Pence some consideration for
that pardon some of these other scumbags
absolutely not they deserve everything
that's coming and everything that
they're gonna get [__] them and I think
that's how he looks at it too [__] him
um I want to pull up a comment here and
I think I got this guy Pete too says
Tony is the anti-rush Limbaugh three
hours
someone calling for three hours I have
been called before the Limbaugh of the
left now Rachel bidikoffer I think she
calls me that and several people have
called me Lynn the Limbaugh of the left
I actually don't take offense to it some
people would some people might take
offense to be gone that but I do not
take offense to be called the Limbaugh
the left because the way I see it is
it's not exactly about rush in that
sense and then it's about the the
effective change that Rush made with
lies maybe I
Tony Michaels can do it with the truth
maybe just maybe and I we we should
we should have three hours um yeah
some people say three hour Friday
because a bonehead Bonet Bonet has put
us at about two and a half hours
the last several Fridays
what are you gonna do what the hell you
gonna do
Eva I I don't I can't I I can't
I can only do what I can do with the
time that we have because there's so
much so many so oh such a big stack of
boneheads
we have to go through it we just have to
get through it we just have to uh
someone asked you Mike Pence was seeking
a pardon I I don't think Mike Pence was
seeking apart maybe I'm wrong on that I
don't know that there's any evidence
that Mike Pence was seeking a pardon
Mike Pence was definitely with his legal
counsel if you watched any of the
hearings if you watched our coverage of
the hearing you can actually go back and
watch the hearing coverage that we had
it's a lot many hours
um I believe it's damn near 30 hours but
the point is this well more with the
commentary the point is this is that I
don't know that there was any evidence
Pence was looking for a pardon I believe
there's evidence to show that they were
trying to prevent that he needed
that he needed a pardon
I believe is the actual language you
would use is that him and his legal
staff between the election and January
6. and even after we're trying to make
sure that he didn't need
a pardon
um I think is the correct language you
would use
and someone says in America's voice
discarded on YouTube says Tony's the
voice of democracy
that's a that's a good one that's a good
one I've never thought of it in that
terms before in that way wording I I try
to make sure
that my commentary is genuine meaning
it's truly what I me Tony Michaels
believes I really try to keep it all
genuine and the reason why is because I
I think that authenticity will show
through to you because you don't have to
agree with me on every single point
and we what we won't agree on every
single point we never will and if and if
I try to agree with the entire audience
on every single point I'm going to fail
immediately
there's going to be a lot of stuff you
disagree with me on a lot of people have
been battling me the last several days
the last several days about well last
several weeks About Me Knocking tyt and
David packman because they go after the
left I listen when I attack tyt and
Pac-Man I'm going after the left
[__] boneheads think about it I'm
calling them out they call out Democrats
yeah yeah I'm calling them out I'm
calling them out I will call out anyone
who encourages people not to vote every
[__] time every single time I don't
even give a [__] if it's a republican
voting We should strive for a hundred
percent of people who are eligible to
vote to vote in this country we will be
better off we will get much better
results as a democracy of what we want
to have happen and how far we want to go
with some of our policies and not go
with some of our policies to be quite
Frank and we will have more Liberty more
equality and more Equity if we do that
that is what I believe I fundamentally
believe in the institution of democracy
I I actually think our democracy in the
way of the two-party system is one of
the best in the world some people will
highly disagree with me on that
but our politics are such that deliver
us over a period of time
more equality and Equity if
if we put ourselves ourselves because
it's our government in a situation
where our democracy operates on the
majority ideology not
the party because I think the parties
will adopt a certain ideology to become
in the majority it's the whole idea but
you know
excuse me for not knowing the structure
of our democracy so thank you for um the
compliment Tony's the voice of the
Democracy someone else here says
Province Supply Province Supply you've
been around here for a long time
I I like to give shout outs especially
to people who were OG [__] fan and
profense Supply here is OG [__] em fam
for a long time you've been here
listening almost every single day for a
long time you say Rush Limbaugh the left
is a compliment Tony absolutely I
believe that I believe people calling me
the Limbaugh the left is an absolute
compliment and here's the other thing
that I want to tell you
because it's a dirty little secret I
guess I don't know [__] them though do
you have any idea do you have any idea
how many people would come and watch
this show and listen to what I have to
say in the way that I say it and I know
a lot of people don't like what I say
and the way that I say it but I don't
give a [__] I don't care like I said I'm
trying to be genuine and trying to be
authentic a lot of people try to get me
to stop saying the f word oh you can't
say [__] you'll never be nationally
syndicated on radio how are you ever
going to be on National Airwaves if you
don't stop saying the word [__] I'm not
gonna stop saying [__] I'm not gonna do
it
that's just what I want to say how I
want to say it that's what I want to do
I'll say bastard [__] [__] I'll say all
kinds of curse words I'm just going to
do it that way
that's what feels right to me
but
if
if people out there who used to be Rush
Limbaugh fans think about this or know
who Rush Limbaugh is like yeah that's my
dude I love that racist piece of [__]
I mean you know you know you know what
I'm talking about you have an uncle you
have a cousin that used to listen to
rushland ball now they listen to Steve
Bannon you know what I'm talking about
you know that [__]
just imagine if they found out that
there's someone on the left that is
known as the Limbaugh of the left
that they come listen I would bet they'd
come listen and I'm not saying I'm going
to convert these people
to the left
but I'll make them think
make them consider
maybe maybe just get him mad enough that
they paint themselves into a corner
about their arguments just saying it
seems to be working it seems to be
working with these moglodytes in
Congress I don't know if you watched I
mean we did some of the dunking
yesterday the Democrats and liberals did
on these on these [__] traders in
Congress that only want to talk about
Hunter Biden's [__] and they only and
they only want to talk about how the the
Democrats are weaponizing the government
when it was the [__] Republicans and
Trump weaponizing the government against
American citizens
they that's all they want to talk about
they don't want they remember how they
said inflation is the number one issue
well now that inflation is going down
they definitely can't have a hearing on
that
[__] no I hate prices gas prices well
those prices are going down how the hell
can they have a committee meeting on
that that ain't going to work out well
for them
and it doesn't seem that the hunter
Biden [__] committee
or the Twitter files committee or the
weaponization committee is doing them
any good either
and the reason why is because a language
like mine yes I'm patting myself on the
back
yes I am I am when you have someone like
me that can say whatever the [__] they
want whenever the [__] they want no one
can stop them
you are the only reason why I do this
and can do this right if you stop
watching I'd stop cursing
because you'd stop watching
but because you watch we got their nuts
in a ringer we got their nuts in a
ringer and I don't just mean Maga I mean
anyone else out there who needs to form
National narrative and National
messaging I don't know if you've watched
some videos of Hakeem Jeffries the
minority leader in the house that
[__] holy sh I am and I've said
this before I am super excited about
Hakeem Jeffries
being speaker of the house 2024. this is
something we must deliver to the
American people
Hakeem Jeffries understands and and it's
a great historical moment that a black
man would become the minority leader and
to be and to rise to speaker of the
house as young as he is
as clear as it could be with the support
of democracy in this country that he
would be
the the Speaker of the House for many
many many terms and many decades
possibly there could be almost 20 years
straight in a row that Hakeem Jeffries
could be speaker of the house but the
thing that gets me so fired up so fired
up about Hakeem Jeffries is he
understands two [__] things two
things
well I guess three if you want to count
but the first thing is that there's two
separate things there's government and
policy and there's [__] elections he
understands this there's tooth and he's
clear that he understands that because
he understands messaging and and
narrative
messaging and narrative
that is what he understands more than
anything every single word that leaves
his lips
is well thought through that filter
that is what will win elections and when
the pro-democracy Coalition in this
country win elections then the
pro-democracy Coalition can do democracy
you see the problem is is in our
two-party system right now we have one
party who wants to destroy democracy so
we can't we can't do democracy with them
there's there is no playing field where
we negotiate and we and we do democracy
with them because they want to destroy
it
we can only operate on the terms of
democracy between our Coalition that's
it
that's why we seem so divided which
we're not [__] divided this is
nonsense it's this country is 50 50.
that 50 of the country is delusional and
believes delusional [__] about laptops
and [__] Twitter files and the other
half is woke meaning they know the
[__] truth and they can tell the
truth when they see it and they can
definitely tell a [__] lie and
delusional [__] when they see it
that's what you mean by divided it's not
it's not 50 50. that is such a [__]
lie
and and everyone gaslights everyone on
that point the media is horrible at it
the media is horrible at acting like
that the country is divided 50 50. that
it's a horrible thing that they do
because they're not and and the reason
why the media does it is because oh
you're the liberal media you're no I'm
liberal media I am
I am unabashed liberal media folks
I'm left-wing media
me
that's what I am
their [__] journalist
and the only reason why it seems left
are liberal is because our country is
left and liberal you [__] boneheads
the majority of the country does not
agree with almost any policy point that
the [__] Republicans would make in
the first place when you narrow it down
to what the actual policy does even
though they [__] vote for it they
still don't agree with it again I'll
give you a prime example in my home
state of Missouri
in this last 2022 midterm
the entire State overwhelmingly voted
for recreational marijuana
overwhelmingly on those same exact
[__] ballots on the same exact
ballots they voted for one of the most
anti-marijuana United States senator in
in this state
Eric Schmidt the former Attorney General
he's now a United States Senator and
he's one of the most anti-marijuana
[__] out there you explain that
to me how in the [__] world does a
state vote overwhelmingly for
recreational marijuana and vote for a
state United States Senator that would
tear it down in a moment
because they don't know better
they don't know they vote based on
affiliation
not based on what that policies they
want instituted if we had that God damn
we'd have gun reform yesterday the day
before [__] 10 years ago
15 years ago we'd have gun reform the
moment the moment that they covered up
the bodies in Newtown of those children
we would have had gun reform
if we had the minor the majority
ideology in our government and people
weren't [__] voting based on
affiliation
but that's how it works that's what
we're dealing with and that's why we
have to undo it
and the only way we undo it is for the
media to be responsible not to act like
they're liberal because that's the
listen just because the truth supports
the liberal ideology doesn't mean it's
not the [__] truth and doesn't mean
that it's liberal
just because you have a certain set of
facts amongst you in a liberal democracy
we are a liberal democracy most [__]
policy points in this country and most
reform and most people's idea of Reform
is going to be naturally liberal go look
up the [__] word go look it up it
means freedom
it means the opportunity of choice it
means equity and equality you [__]
boneheads go look it up
that's why they struggle
right that's why they struggle and they
have to Rebrand us as woke
because you know they they don't have a
definition for woke woke is whatever
they want it to believe well they lock
they lock them people will kill or wait
too much they're woke oh my God they
want they want people not to be not to
exist if you want to be lgbtq and you
want to marry who you want love who you
want you want to be you want to identify
how you want to be and it's not
bothering anybody but you will that's
what they want yeah we want Liberty we
want Liberty and we don't we don't we
want you to stay out of other people's
[__] business it's what we want stay
the mind your own [__] business
but that's why the country isn't divided
50 50 and that's why the media always
gets it wrong
they always get it wrong not here
because I'm liberal media I don't have
to hide under the guise of oh well I'm
I'm non-biased
no I pick a side and it's called liberal
I pick a side it's called democracy I
pick a [__] side it's liberty it's
Freedom it's Choice it's equity and
equality
that's what that's the side I'm on
that's the side and that's why when you
tell me that I'm on the same side as tyt
and David Pacman we may be on the same
side but they are not on the side of
democracy
they aren't they're not they're not
when they encourage people not to vote
because it doesn't matter you're not on
the side of democracy you're not on the
side of Liberty you're not on the side
of choice
you're not you're just you're just not
so I'll keep calling them out I'll keep
calling out the left
so there you go
it's the explanation I guess I don't
know what do you want for me
let's see where's Gabe Sanchez is
oh he should be coming in here soon I
gotta check in uh to see where we're at
on the um
on the bonehead of the week
um assets you guys know the special
Graphics that we have Gabe Sanchez makes
all those great graphics
any a great
um executive producer and co-host
fantastic he's one he's the best best in
the business and I don't know if you
guys know this he's got a show that he
hosts on his own called what was that
you have to check these out you have to
check out what was that one of the
easiest ways if you're on Twitter is go
to his page I am Gabe Sanchez or go to
what was that show
on Twitter and you can follow that stuff
you post stuff there we've been posting
it on the community tab here on the
YouTube channel too just just go over to
I am Gabe Sanchez on YouTube and follow
his YouTube channel he puts all those
episodes there I really I honestly think
that show may be that show's gonna take
off
you can watch it over on the Midas touch
Network and they post it over there
um
on the mydist touch Network the the what
was that but he's got a playlist on and
there's the playlist is on our Channel
too so if you subscribe to the Tony
Michaels podcast here on YouTube you can
find that playlist here on the front
page the what was that playlist and it's
gapped all the episodes I believe
there's 30 or more than 30. I don't know
he's got a lot of episodes
kind of caught up with me I've had to go
back and watch uh re-watch a few of them
but um go go go go check out what was
that
um because I want you to support not
just me but I want you to support our
co-host and executive producer Gabe
Sanchez he's gonna he's gonna also have
a patreon that's going to be dedicated
to extra content involving what was that
um and I ask you to to consider
supporting him there as well I think
he's gonna have it done over the weekend
um but I I would really appreciate if
you if you go uh support
our guy Gabe Sanchez our co-host and
executive producer I know all of you
love Gabe
so just go to his YouTube channel or
again you can subscribe here and I wish
we have the playlist of all his what was
that's here on our Channel as well
um and I I believe that what was that is
going to be a good piece a great piece
of content coming into this election
cycle I think it's going to be important
because he takes these issues and he
breaks them down he makes them you know
digestible it's almost like The Daily
Show
um sort of like a monologue on The Daily
Show or a late night Daily Show
um foggy Ozark said I subscribed last
week to Gabe it's fantastic let's get
him as many subscribers over there as we
possibly can on his YouTube channel
and again the the list
um for his what was that the playlist if
you want to watch all of them is here on
our front home page on the Tony Michaels
podcast channel so follow that as well
and also you can follow him on Twitter
and I am Gabe Sanchez and he post clips
and new things that he's doing with the
show over there as well and I'm sure
he'll be doing all that on his uh
patreon if you want to support that
piece of content
and make sure uh Gabe Sanchez can
continue to do what was that for years
to come especially into the 2024 uh
general election because I I'm not
telling you I know this for sure
then there's going to be a republican
nominee that's going to be Donald Trump
and there's going to be Democratic
nominee it's going to be Joe Biden
that's what it's going to be even even
though Mike Pence may flip
here and may give Jack Smith the Evan
said he needs to indict Trump
and his closest allies of the coup
um he's still going to run
because being indicted on federal
charges does not prevent you from
running for president
it's not I mean he can still run he can
still seek the nomination they'll give
it to him too I don't know if you've
seen Chris sununu but let's do this I'm
not going to play the music for the
shitless Roundup but let me show you uh
because Chris Nunu and was uh
what's trending I showed you a clip of
him the other day
um where
yeah he was talking about Donald Trump
being the nominee and not being the
nominee and
um he's going to be the nominee now
sununu doesn't believe that he's going
to be the nominee but you know what
Kristen again soon calls him a [__]
joke and all kinds of crazy [__]
let me see if I can find
me
I think that's it
um you deal with it dude no that's not
it I I Chris nunu
well
um
so he was on
uh Morning Joe this morning
but the one clip I want to show you here
is he was on Fox News
uh uh Cavuto caboodle show Neil Cavuto
show and here is the um
here's the clip here where he's saying
Donald Trump won't be the nominee yes he
will Chris and and even if he is I will
vote for him
this guy [__] hates Trump this guy
[__] hates Trump but listen to this
same thing all right in the end if
Donald Trump pull it out and and picked
off what could be whoa Donald Trump is
going to pull it out
oh he means he means well well you never
know what Donald Trump let's let's
continue proud of field as he did in
2016. would you support him
oh well I'm I'm I am a lifelong
Republican and I'm going to support the
Republican nominee I don't necessarily
think it's going to be Donald Trump but
I'm going to support the Republican
nominee everybody should there you go
remember what remember just I don't know
it seemed like a it seemed like so long
ago when I was talking about how
affiliation is the reason why we have to
live with these Traders remember that
that was so long ago that I was talking
about that it couldn't have been just in
the last half hour
um listen this is why Donald Trump will
be the nominee this is why affiliation
DeSantis can't handle it Nikki Haley
can't handle it Larry Hogan will not be
able to handle it Kemp the governor
Georgia will not be able to handle it
they will not be able to get in this
race without being destroyed
is why Donald Trump will win by
affiliation because oh well you gotta
vote for him I hate that [__]
he's a traitor but boy he's a republican
what
this is this is the world that we live
in
I don't know what I don't know what else
to do for you
this is just the [__] [__] we got to
deal with
um speaking of Traders
here's another Trader I'm not going to
play a whole lot of this this is Chris
Miller this is the guy who who took over
his acting
uh depart our defense secretary after
the election
after the election and in the lead up to
the [__] Cheeto dust kangaroo coup
Chris Miller was appointed the acting
secretary acting you got me
now he's a career military but his new
book let me get to that part here
let me get to that part that's there it
is okay so his new book is called
um where the [__] is it go
let's play
of course it's gonna load you gotta be
[__] me
you gotta be kidding me okay let me let
me redo the page seeing how to refresh
the page here in [__]
oh man
big trouble okay it's a long video it's
like seven minutes
someone must have had their Twitter blue
account going okay so here is the book
by Christopher C Miller
it's called Soldier secretary you see
that Soldier secretary this guy was not
a secretary
he was not the Secretary of Defense he
was the acting Secretary of Defense
he was never he was never vetted by our
Senate our government the way it's
supposed to work for a Cabinet member
it's the way it's supposed to work
acting is not secretary
okay especially especially when you are
appointed to make sure that no problems
arise when you're trying to I don't know
commit a coup
now he claims in this interview with
Steve Bannon talking about Traders uh to
love cash Patel that's about all you
need to know to go that he's on Steve
Bannon show and he loves cash Patel
here's a problem Morning Joe had this
[__] on this morning and I don't
know what he said on Morning Joe but
apparently he was on morning Joe's show
this morning pimping this stupid book to
me I've never been in the military
I was never in the military
wasn't
but to me
he's not stealing Valor as a soldier
because he was he was in the military
but his book title called Soldier
secretary it really feels like Stolen
Valor on the secretary part doesn't it
doesn't it feel a little Santos like
doesn't it when you're when you're doing
that when you're like oh
oh it's uh oh
it's uh kind of like that I mean I was
acting I was appointed to make sure a
coup went over but you know to overturn
our government
[__] out here let's listen to a little
bit of this the end of this Vision he
said let's go do it and uh we couldn't
get through the the middle layer the the
Frozen middle of the bureaucracy and of
course cash had a relationship with the
president he was able to just go right
in say hey Mr President you're getting
slow rolled by these people and that was
our goal and that's what we decided to
do and that's what we uh did did pretty
well if you ask me
so they really did well try to to uh
attempt to overthrow our government Gabe
Sanchez they did that really well like
like they did that really [__] well I
mean it went off without a hitch right
so this guy loves cash Patel and he goes
on in this interview with Steve Bannon
which again I I wish I had time
not uh to play the whole clip but it's
like eight minutes longer this [__]
idiots show the point is that Chris
Miller has been doing the circuits on
real media he's pimping his book called
Soldier secretary this guy was appointed
secretary after the election because the
dod's secretary the defense secretary is
not esper was not telling Trump what he
wanted him to hear this Chris Miller was
appointed as acting not not vetted by
our government that we appointed by the
Senate which is how members of the
cabinet are actually
um you know certified and vetted by our
government that we elect that that the
president just nominates them right
they're confirmed by the Senate
our government by us
but this guy is claiming to be the the
real secretary by calling himself the
secretary Soldier I feel like and I
think it's kind of Stolen Valor in a way
I mean I'm not stealing away as Valor
for the word Soldier but it should be
Soldier acting secretary not Soldier
secretary let's let's be honest yeah
I would not uh I mean I think it's a
it's a little bit of an you know I'm not
saying that anyone is uh pulling a
George Santos but you know the idea that
the person is embellishing their resume
or their
um exaggerating what their position is
uh you know that's it's you know it's
the Republican way of life right we've
talked about it before and and I don't
think this is any different from the
idea that they
we'll just say what they they'll just
make it up and they'll be like I am I am
the President of Mars and you're like
wait what and you're like well you can't
prove that I'm not and you're like right
well show me where I'm not like right
what and and show me where Mars exist
either like what okay this is really
weird like you're saying two things it's
really weird speaking of George Santos
and I know we're probably gonna replay
this clip because you hosting one so
I'll probably replay it differently I
also have I also have a development on a
story that I will be
okay well let's let me show this clip
because I'm glad you invoked
um George Santos there I mean I said a
few times in the mirror this morning and
he'd like all right he like flickered in
the background and then he disappeared
so it's like Beetlejuice type thing or
yeah yeah but it was just like it was
kind of like in Harry Potter where like
you know you get the little trading card
and then the person appears there for a
moment and then they wish away I never
watched Harry Potter didn't read them
either it's Wizardry it's witchcraft you
know it's anti exactly George Santos
George Santos is which witchcraft he's
okay so is it George Anthony witchcraft
devolder Santos is witchcraft in his
name then actually all of the letters in
the word witchcraft make up all of my
words in George Sanchez if you do like
the dematria or whatever move it around
exactly yeah okay good okay well just
just checking the reason why I want to
show this clip and why it's so funny is
because you just invoked George Santos
and then you said like kernels of truth
right like it's true but is it really
true because this [__] clip with Greg
Kelly is so [__] hilarious on that on
Newsmax you can't even make this [__]
like I really thought this could be like
Saturday Night Live could just lift this
thing this 59 seconds and do it you know
uh you know just kind of mocking it a
little and it would go over really well
watch this the journey wasn't easy you
know uh I've taken some sacrifices and
some hits in the face but I stand here
to say confidently that to say that I
deceived and it was a campaign of Deceit
and deception is just not fair that's
just the political spin that the Nassau
County GOP wants to create on this
narrative and as you as you know New
York politics it's pretty simple the
party bosses run the narrative and
everyone follows suit and this is what's
going on at the moment is it playing on
your end or is it frozen it's like
Frozen on my end can you hear it it was
I heard like it
uh can the audience hear it can the
audience hear it I don't know can the
audience hear it I don't know I can't
hear it no I think they can hear it I
think I think it was weird it was just
like dude your your connections but
here's the thing I can see you and I can
hear you no problem I know because I'm
awesome
well all right anyway everyone says it's
just me yeah yes I'll just go [__]
myself yeah later you can just [__] off
just like George Santos okay let's let's
watch Greg Kelly's response because Greg
Kelly kinda goes after him here right
but the way that he goes after him with
projection is like oh it's just so
[__] beautiful it's just like you you
do you are so funny Shameless Newsmax
right and Greg Kelly specifically you
know you know you probably stepped in a
huge pile of [__] let's listen to the
huge pile of [__]
did you survive a brain tumor
um I had my own personal medical issues
uh in the past and I I don't feel I need
to go into details but yes I did have uh
an acute tumor this is what can so so
hemorrhoids he had hemorrhoids I'm I'm
unclear is it a brain tumor is it
hemorrhoids I can't decide here because
it's a medical issue right that he's
dealing with but I I love how Greg Kelly
goes to one of his lies that would be
this would be one of the easiest
provable lies that George Santos could
could prove that it's not a lie like he
literally he literally could release his
own
some sort of record to show that he had
some sort of procedure or something done
or to clarify or not clarify the whole
brain tumor thing he could do that more
than likely but he won't because it is a
[__] line everyone knows it's like
but the point here is is that great
Kelly is is painting him in a corner for
this this next moment because this next
moment is the moment where great Kelly
does the whole oh gotcha but it's all
pure 100 unadulterated projection every
[__] last bit of it watch this and
we'll talk about it on the other side
certainly I mean you'll have to admit
you're a Critic of Joe Biden so am I but
it's very biden-esque to take a kernel
of Truth and make it into a possibly
more appealing story for voters that's a
it's by nest really that he's like uh
it's it's at first I thought he was like
oh it's biden-ish like right you know
you're a representative ish you know
congressman-ish but the idea that he was
like oh it's biden-esque right like
that's oh very on the very on par for uh
for Biden type of thing especially
because you know uh George Santos came
out and when people were like oh what do
you what how do you excuse your line he
goes well Joe Biden has a career liar
for 47 years so I should be able to lie
yeah so it's like first off one either
buy it in line or didn't lie if he did
not excusable
also you doing a what about ISM for a
dude who's the president and trying to
say well he lied in these other contexts
doesn't make you line any better right
it's like well that they're like why'd
you murder that man well he murdered
another man is like well that doesn't
that doesn't evil it out like even it
out here that just because you do it
or just because they do it doesn't mean
that you can do it itself because what
about isn't [__]
is just
is hilarious it's republican-ish yeah
it's Republican well no there's no ish
involved propaganda right okay but you
look at this moment and you see George
Santos all of these lies building up and
also based on and we'll get into it this
whole Amish don't you want to do that do
you want to do that yeah or you want to
do it or do you want to do it now I'm
still loading the assets so I didn't
know if you want to if you want well
it's a little bit it's which one do you
want me to talk about the the Amish
which one are you serious you get you
got you got more of them yeah I got one
that no one's got and then I've got I've
so I'm gonna I'm gonna be tweeting this
out a little bit I gotta just got to
confirm One Last Detail with the source
and this is a story that nobody has
there's also on George Santos on George
Santos this is and then there's another
story which broke yesterday and then
it's from Jacqueline sweet who is the
patch reporter you want to do that story
now or you want to do that one and which
one you want to do in bonus let's do one
on bonehead and do one of them now
I can do the
non-patch story or the non-uh the
non-political Amish so the one mill
Story the one that you okay yeah okay
let's do that let's talk about that okay
so as you all know I've been digging
around and I've I was gonna do a whole
video
no pun intended no no no no pun intended
anyway I've been digging I've been
digging around as you know I've been
talking about it and I was gonna do a
full video on this now one of my one of
the stories I was gonna do was on this
organization that we also talked about
earlier this week with Texas Paul that
story broke and I was like oh [__] okay
so I now need to break the story now
this there's a recent story that
happened yesterday
but I've been in I've been in contact
with people at a former rescue in the
New Jersey area that George Santos
worked with is this under the uh the
charity that that also took the money
from the veteran with his dog
there's his there's his uh fake
non-profit because there is no
non-profit that is registered in any
state of Delaware New York New Jersey
anywhere no no friends of pets United no
fopu nothing nothing with the IRS I have
gone through and audited
every possible document I can to find it
I can't find it nothing there not
registered not a real thing when you are
registered you get an official letter
that says you are you get the 501c3
status uh there's a whole thing there's
no record of it no record ever anywhere
anywhere
so the idea was that George Sanchez was
saying it was a it was a charity it was
real it was a non-profit it was telling
people it's tax deductible it wasn't it
was never a real thing
now this is what I found out there is a
photo of George Santos and I'll load it
in yeah um to here
is it him or is it Anthony devolder well
at the time it was Anthony devolder so
he was going by Anthony devalder right
right so I don't know if this will take
up the full screen I don't think it will
so this is the photo right here so as
you can see this is George Santos AKA
Anthony divulder AKA Anthony zabrovsky
AKA George
uh Anthony devolder Santos uh AKA Katara
ravash AKA I'm losing names to go by
here but anyway this is George Santos
there was an event in 2015 in New Jersey
with an organization called iron-bound
Animal Rescue
and this was the only benefit they had
because it looks like this rescue was
only around for one year okay now they
still have stuff on Facebook and they
still have a group and they still you
know talk to each other but there's no
like non-profit it took three years and
the non-profit status lapsed because
they stopped running the organization as
a non-profit and they weren't filing so
this is what happens in 2015 George
Santos AKA Anthony volder at that point
in time gets linked up through another
person from New York City with this
group of Brazilians and other people who
are
um just just a non-non-american
community of people that just want to
help dogs and Foster dogs and find them
their their forever homes
so he works with them on a handful of
occasions like probably like three
occasions he shows up and he has this
this benefit dinner with them in
September of 2015.
takes the photos schmoozes all the stuff
uses the organization as a way to like
oh I'll help you fundraise I've got all
these connections so he does his own
thing there
now on about three different occasions
they worked uh with George Santos
meaning that he volunteered for the
organization
to help Foster and transport dogs now
they're like again three times or so
that they used him he picked up the dogs
from where the foster home was and then
he would take them to where the the
adopted family's home was okay
he'd pick them up at night they would
stay overnight at his house and then a
couple days later or so he would drop
them off at whatever the the adopted
family's home is now on one occasion and
this is where things go south for the
relationship between Anthony devolder
George Santos and this Ironbound rescue
now he was doing all this under the the
fopu yeah is that so he was saying I'm
Anthony divulder and I've got this
organization but he was doing it as
officially as that organization that
you're saying does not exist as a 501c3
exactly okay so he would pick up these
dogs transport them and drop them off at
the foster home
um and typically would be like oh I've
got a family that I know that'll take
the dog and they pick him up and he drop
him off
now on one occasion there were two small
dogs and they don't exactly remember the
breed the person I spoke to said
possibly it could be two uh miniature
Pinchers it's like little little
Doberman Pinschers minis
um but believes that they were two two
dogs
so the way that it goes is George Santos
picked up the dogs and took them to
whatever this family was right and
typically the new family the new
permanent family and he'd share that
information with the organization to say
hey this is where they are so then the
organization would follow up and be like
hey how are the dogs doing do you need
anything can we provide you any help
blah blah blah right typical follow-up
so according allegedly now I'm using
this allegedly because uh there's some
questions as to like I don't have the
documents but this is all based on on
their accounts so allegedly George
Santos found a family got the dogs
dropped them off
and then later the family was like we
can't have these dogs anymore we don't
want these dogs for whatever reason it
could have been behavioral but I don't
know the specifics on why they didn't
want whereas where the dog should go
right
now
he was in charge of finding the second
home and he said he found a second home
he said I found a second home I found
another family for these dogs okay
and they said okay great
and they started saying well what's the
information can you provide us the
information George Santos doesn't
provide information they say well we
need you know we need to know where the
dogs you know where the dog went so that
we can follow up
didn't give him anything excuse after
excuse after excuse just [__] now
the length of time in which they tried
to find out what's going on
is I'm unknown to the details because
again this is seven years ago eight
years ago so it's you know a long time
for people they're doing some of this on
recollection as well right so so it's
the people that are at this the at this
Foundation or this or this rescue and
they're telling me the story and they're
saying look at this point in time we
don't know where the dogs are we don't
know where the dogs are we don't know
the whereabouts we don't know the status
we're supposed to go to this one family
he said he had the family he said he
found another family he dropped him off
now
to this day the rescue does not know the
whereabouts of these two small dogs
and not only that
but now the question comes into did
George Santos find a new home for these
two small dogs these innocent small dogs
or did he just abandon them on the
street
and then scam people with a GoFundMe
that's the big question now I don't have
the answers there and the only person I
can answer that is George Santos Anthony
De Boulder Katara rabosh but we know
that he won't right we know it or the
organization fopu that apparently does
not exist right I mean I can tell you
right now that George Santos claims that
he ran the organization from 2013 to
2018 but I can tell you for a fact
that up until 2021 George Santos was
still asking for payments online through
fopu I can tell you for a fact that even
in 2020 George Santos was still running
a puppy mill scam
so so
do you think we'll ever find out the
whereabouts of these two dogs or do you
think the dogs are gone
it's hard to say you know it would
really because there there's the
original family that got the dogs and
then for whatever the reason they said
we can't handle the dogs and we can't
have these so we need to give them up so
then George Santos says okay fine I'll
take the dogs back and I'll find them a
new home at that point the family
doesn't know anything right they're like
oh we tried with the dogs but for some
reason it didn't behavioral reasons or
whatever it didn't work out so at that
point the family
is done right they have no connection to
the dog anymore
and so now the only person who knows the
whereabouts of this dog is
George Santos or if somebody can recall
George Santos helping these dogs out
because that's that was going to be my
next question is is is the The Story
Goes that George Santos personally
delivered these dogs like that's the way
that it would work he'd pick up the dogs
at night they would stay overnight for a
day it was actually him him Anthony to
Boulder whatever whatever Alias he was
using he would pick them up for him he
would he would come forward or he would
he would pick up the dogs at night
he would Foster them for a day or two
and then deliver them and drop them off
at whatever the the adopted family the
forever home is so let me ask you
was he being paid as a service for this
or was it just it was just this was I'm
I'm doing these things supporting me
give me donations and these so there's
no there's no
um
no payment there's no transaction ever
from from what I saw and who I've spoken
to there was never a transaction because
Anthony devolder George Santos only
worked as a volunteer with this rescue
now he helped fundraise
for this rescue through fopu right and I
don't know if he ever got money that was
then handed off that seems to be there's
a lot of question here the people a lot
of the people that I'm speaking to are
um
but which fopu doesn't exist right fopu
is not a real thing he had a logo so is
that where is that where you were saying
is that where you're saying the fraud
happens is
this guy is collecting what what some
are saying is is 501c3 non-profit funds
right um and he's doing the bare minimum
to appear that there is a non-profit not
even the bare minimum of not even filing
I mean he's just printing signs and
telling people that it exists right it
doesn't actually exist he also had and
we will go into this in bonehead but
basically the news that broke yesterday
with a reporter that I've been in
contact with since uh
I since a few weeks ago there was
something that broke and I started
looking into it basically
he ran a puppy mill operation and would
so he was he was creating the problem
yes so he would have these adoption
events with certain places and that's
and that's the thing we're going to
break in bone him and that's we're going
to break okay well let's do that
um one last question that I have yeah
about this because you're saying this
was one instance with this one
organization yeah and after that then
they they're like oh this guy's real
shady we don't they wouldn't operate
with him after that no no is there any
is there any indication of how many of
these these um
dog deliveries that he did where he was
Finding families was there is there any
indication of how many and that he
actually did based on the person I spoke
to they said that they were called uh a
few times so so we're not talking like a
few times a week we're talking no no
like few times total it only happened in
2015. okay so now my next my next
question is this
is
um is there any other organization out
there that was doing the same thing with
fopu which is the non-existent
non-profit is there any other
organization that was doing this exact
thing there was another organization I
don't know if there was the picking up
and dropping off but he did work with
another Organization for the adoption
type thing the adoption yeah yeah for
for fundraising is what he did and he
did not actually
um
follow through with a promise like he
promised he or he said he raised
thousands of dollars for
um for this one
uh this one rescue and then gave them
like four hundred dollars at the end and
then there was also the story that uh I
I talked about earlier this week so wait
a second so you're saying you raised a
certain amount of money and then only
gave a percentage of it do you think do
you think he was charging
um these organizations for his Services
of raising money for them you think that
I don't think he from I mean that was
his thought process yeah like I don't
from what I've gathered so far I I can't
say that's what happened
right right I don't think well here's
the thing
I don't know
if he ever took money without them
knowing now that's not to say that he
didn't but I can tell you from the
people I've spoken to they were like no
no no what do you mean by that what you
mean by that is that he would use their
organization's name without them knowing
and collecting money or use or or with
their knowledge but then not giving them
the full amount right
like there's the there's the uh Andrea
dos Santos who had the tooth Acre Farm
in New Jersey who there was a story in
the New York Times that I brought up and
we showed a screenshot of that right of
that uh
um
right and so in there they had raised
2165 the tickets were sold at 58 a pop I
think what you could do and there's a
raffle and what have you but at the end
he never gave that money over so he
pocketed the 2165 so they were still
saying one of the last conversations
that this woman had the owner of this
farm with George Santos was is you know
karma's going to get you
uh and you know it's taken a bit of time
because karma is getting there where it
is really really building up so um so
yeah so that's the that's the oh that's
a story that no one else has I'm gonna
be releasing that in a little bit with a
little Twitter thread good good
um where are you are you gonna put it on
your page you're gonna put it I'm gonna
put it on the what was that page and
then uh and then after that yeah when
you want to share it and then I'll I'll
retweet it and so everybody be watching
for that just go to app what was that
show uh on Twitter or you go to I am
Gabe Sanchez and I think you get the
link it's in the bio yeah yeah his link
is in the link in the bio and go into
there or you can watch my account
or the show account at Tony Michaels pod
will will be retweeting out let's do
this let's let's take a quick break and
when we come back we will go to bone in
the league that way we can cover the the
other Santos yeah fraud holy moly we'll
be right back with bonehead of the week
right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babble
Mega Edition makes it really easy to
learn and there's lots of lessons to
choose from like subtly racist to
full-blown white supremacists the first
lesson began with learning simple
phrases and soon I was putting those
words and phrases into a conversation
each lesson takes about 10 to 15 minutes
to complete and they're all really
different which keeps things interesting
the app is really smart it actually
keeps track of the words that I'm
struggling with I chose Babel mag
Edition because it's created by smart
white people like me and now I can't
wait to explore meet new friends and use
my new Mega skills with my in-laws all
lives matter
foreign
this is the Tony Michaels podcast
there you have it just gave us an
exclusive story be watching at what was
that show on Twitter
for the for the thread that exposes
George Santos and the allegations
against him
it is puppy scheme
[Music]
whenever the hell whatever the hell it's
called Welcome to Bone end of the week
bonehead of the week
we're gonna talk about George Sanchez in
this segment too and here's what I want
you to do because you're gonna have some
stuff going on over the weekend for what
was that on patreon correct you want to
tell the audience what's going I tried
to explain it earlier but you know that
yeah yeah you got the skin yeah
but we'll begin in the bone of the week
over the weekend yeah so over the
weekend I'm going to be working on uh
finishing up the my uh you know official
patreon I decided finally to jump in and
do one
um just to support the effort of you
know my content and what was that you
know it takes a lot of time great show
by the way thank you thank you uh but
yeah it's you know I'm are you at 30 or
31 I've been trying to I'm 31 is I'm
about to finish up 31 today 31's close
so yeah so then by the end of the
weekend there will be 31 and then maybe
a 32 on Monday like that many it seems
like just I don't know a month or two
ago when you were like what should I
call this thing which like we went back
and forth with the background right
about four or five different ones yeah
yeah we've had a lot I was like what
he's got to be gotta be quick you know
gotta be some short you know and then I
want to tell the audience the pizza
content that you see with what was that
he didn't just like flop that it's not
like a my thing where I just whoop there
it is
he he worked for weeks on what what was
that would actually be so
um I'm actually I actually love that
piece of content and I think the
audience should go support it as much as
they possibly can whether you go to the
Twitter page and share it just go watch
it give him likes share it with your
your family your friends share the link
around to people who are like-minded
also if you can and this weekend with
patreon uh go support game and we'll
we'll have you'll have that link on your
link tree right yeah yeah I'll have the
link on there and so I'm thinking that
I'll probably do like a little soft
launch on Sunday so it'll be live on
Sunday but then Monday for the show okay
cool we'll announce it uh yeah and maybe
we'll even have a special graphic I'm
sure I'm sure Sanchez will have a
Graphic for his page I'll make something
my graphic for my patreon probably is
was not near as fancy as what he'll get
because it'll be down to the detail so
please um give give it to your support
and if you like you can go check out my
patreon too just go to the Tony
michaels.com you can check out mine as
well and we appreciate all your support
of our content and continued support not
just not just paid support because
that's important for us to keep going
but also when you guys show up here live
every every single weekday and you're
here for two full hours you're here for
bone end of the week you go watch Gabe's
what was that that's important and again
if you want to watch all the last 30
episodes to get caught up on the 31
that's gonna get really least the
playlist is right on this channel on the
Tony Michaels podcast but don't forget
to go subscribe to Gabe's Channel as
well they're over there as well all
right let's do it
let's get the moon hand of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to this edition of bone net of
the week one of the most bone-headed
weeks that we have experience I mean
I mean it's kind of a every week is like
or can they out bonehead the last week
and you can guarantee Mt they do son of
a [__] I think they're I think
currently as we speak they're doing
bone-headed [__] bone yeah I mean each
each time we've been on the air this
week they're like we're holding a
committee and it's like wow you guys are
really really dumb right they're really
bone-headed it looks like you pulled an
audible here maybe on a couple of these
did I well I mean I I was suggesting
some for the DM and the alpha cook but
yeah I think wait wait wait did I get it
wrong hold on no no no no no you're fine
you're fine whatever I was under the
impression hold on I gotta go back
through my text real quick with you no
no we'll play the clip that I wanted to
play out Alpha yeah wait wait wait hold
on didn't
oh oh I see what I did I see what I did
I see what I did hold on let me flip it
let me flip it hold on give me a second
okay we'll talk about this
so here is our official boneheads that
you the audience vote on because you
know how bone and the work bonehead of
the week works you go to the community
tab on our YouTube page the Tony
Michaels you can vote in the poll there
or you can vote on Twitter at Tony
Michaels pod and of course we have rep
I don't report sex crimes Jim Jordan you
have Jonathan Turley which maybe he's
he's new I don't know that this is a
he's a new one this is his first time on
the show I had this space I had to be
like who is this well you know like I
was like what was that yeah now what was
that no no what was that this is uh I'm
sorry who are you again
I don't have you on the reservation list
who are you oh you're gonna say
who what was that when you hear what he
says the reason why I wanted him on bone
of course he was trending yesterday
because of his testimony in front of the
weaponization committee and then of
course we have Marjorie hoof foot green
otherwise known as the petty Yeti now
here on the Tony Michaels podcast
Eddie Yeti of course if you look at
these three
it's pretty easy to determine who won
because
oh it was it was
by the way it was not even okay it was
not even that name competition that name
never fails I don't know it's not
undefeated I don't think she's
undefeated because back last March when
you did the whole um bracket system she
lost one of those
she did and I'm not trying to give away
one but I am giving it away of course of
course the petty Yeti one of course she
did yeah you know she is a [__] class
a bonehead but let's let's go to
Jonathan Turley first since maybe no one
knows who this is
um for anyone who doesn't know Jonathan
Turley has been a bonehead for a really
long time like a really long time and
the boneheads of the of the Republican
Party love to use him as a boneheaded
witness in their Congressional testimony
he's a Fox News talking head he's a
[__] liar he's a goddamn gaslighter
he's just a republican piece of [__] I
mean again he's Santos right but the way
oh yeah you just gotta watch you just
gotta watch just watch how he's torn
apart here and questioning his expertise
on Twitter this is [__] fantastic
thank you so much Mr Turley uh turning
to you
have you ever worked for Twitter
no do you have any formal relationship
with the company
no I just have an account do you have
any specific he's got an account this is
hilarious he's like well I am an account
holder uh I pay for Twitter blue
I agreed to the terms of service so I'm
an expert I'm an ex as if like he read
through every line and now he knows all
the backstory and all the and the reason
he's about to give to the information
that
or or expertise that he has is pretty
funny and I'll explain I'll explain why
after so let's she's I mean like you can
see like I don't know how Jonathan
Turley doesn't know this that Debbie
Wasserman Schultz is gonna wad him up
and dunk him in the [__] trash here
just in the garbage can here I don't
know but he I don't think he actually
sees it coming here and he she just
destroys him in a matter of a minute and
a half watch specific or special or
unique knowledge about the inner
workings of Twitter
nothing beyond the Twitter files and
what I read in the media so essentially
your responses to the questions here
today were your own opinion and pure
conjecture
no I wouldn't say that I mean they're
based I try to base them on what we know
from the Twitter files well but you said
that you don't have any specific or
unique knowledge of Twitter but you
spoke as if you did you were asked very
specific questions about Twitter's
uh the way Twitter functions and the
decision making that they that they make
but yet you don't have any unique or
special knowledge about Twitter and have
never worked for them and so this is
only just your opinion would you say as
a Twitter account user no I I come to
give legal analysis based on facts that
are in the public domain and I was
really really referring to what the I
was asked about this reclining my time
legal analysis is another word for
opinion
I would think there is some distinction
but yeah it's all ultimately is an
opinion but I believe the question to me
was based on what the Twitter files show
and that that was my reading of the
Twitter phone right and again that's
another way of describing your opinion
being offered which was represented as
unique and special facts which you don't
possess thank you I yield back the
balance of my time
Okay the reason this is so funny other
than the fact that when she's like all
right you know it's the same type of
questions like oh are you a medical
expert are you a doctor no then okay
this is just opinion
and even you know that is opinion too if
you're a medical uh you know a physician
as we've seen through the people that
were surprised
maybe your experience right right yeah
practicing them this guy this guy
Jonathan Turley the reason this is so
funny not only is Jonathan Turley I did
not know who he was until I had to look
up his face to find a photo to put on oh
really yeah yeah I didn't know and then
I was like oh he actually represents the
Sister Wives for the polyamorous uh a
family uh the Mormons there's like all
this other [__] I learned about anyway
the reason this is so funny is because
she's like all right look are you an
employee do you have are you privy to
information he is a lawyer let's start
here he is a lawyer he is a lawyer right
right a real lawyer he's not like Tom
he's a lawyer no I mean I'm not saying
that he's a good lawyer he has a law
license he can practice law again not
saying he's good but he can practice law
and somebody Rudy Giuliani or some other
Trump attorney
but in this moment right now she's like
all right cool do you are you do you
have information do you have inside
information inside knowledge are you
privy to stuff that no one else knows
and he's like well no I just but the
Twitter files are and just for anyone
who doesn't know this to Twitter files
are not open for everyone to look at
right instead of saying hey here are all
the files and the documents people can
go through and and decide what they want
right because right now the Twitter
files are given to one reporter
journalist to report on and then have a
Twitter thread on Twitter that Elon Musk
gets super excited about wait wait
you're telling me that Jonathan Turley
is the only attorney that read those
Twitter threads because that seems to be
his expertise here if that's what you're
that seems to be what he's saying he's
saying I read the entire thread
I read the entire thread the whole thing
not only did he win the entire thread
he's like I read the entire thread I
read the quote tweets and I read the
comments
and that is the amount of legal
expertise analysis AKA opinion because
that's all it is Jonathan Turley knows
nothing more than what uh myself or Tony
or anyone else in the audience by
reading the thread you go oh okay
that's either [__] dumb and that's
not exactly what you guys are claiming
it to be because it's not and we've seen
that multiple multiple times just like
the fact that the Twitter files just
happened to just leave out the fact that
Donald Trump and the White House
contacted uh Twitter to make sure that
they got Chrissy teigen's tweet down
that said LOL what a [__] ass [__] uh
he didn't tag me
um you know the pleasure Mr President
which was her tweet towards uh Donald
Trump and he got so triggered that he
used the White House the federal
government the thing that you and I and
Tony and everyone else pays to support
to go after Twitter and say oh you
should take down the Tweet because
that's very very mean it is it is mean
when you point out that he's a [__] ass
[__] Gabe Sanchez now here's what I
look I didn't say he was a [__] ass
[__] I mean he is a [__] ass [__]
right he is Chrissy Teigen said it and
I'm just quoting her she is pointing and
I'm corroborating her claim that he is
right and I think um I think we're gonna
make some merch uh PAB 45. I think we're
gonna make that merch well yeah gotta
come up with a design uh maybe we'll do
that over the weekend
um here's my take on the Wasserman
Schultz Debbie Wasserman Schultz
this is why I argue that women
should be in power in this country
because Debbie Wasserman Schultz her
experience here is not just as a
congressperson for a very long time and
in government and understanding how
these committee hearings work and how it
works when an expert comes and gives
expert testimony on a subject
but she speaks to him like you've got a
mom Gabe's inches I haven't um when I
was a kid and I did something wrong or I
did something really stupid my mom would
like lean down and she's like looks
did you do this and you're like well
like no no no no no no I'm asking you
directly because it's either one or the
other it can't be both and she just
lightly puts you in your place
um or or what maybe some moms would do
is just Ben Jonathan Turley over their
knee rip down his britches and spank him
with a belt I mean either way you look
at this it's kind of like Jonathan
Turley looked like a little child
um with Mommy washerman Schultz kind of
putting him in his place because he
broke the lamp it really I mean
this is how the Republican Party
response is going to be though and
Democrats have been doing such a good
job of this and the reason why it feels
like over the last several days that
Democrats have been doing such a good
job at this is because really this is
the best line of defense in a Committee
hearing where the Republicans control it
because what you have to remember
is they haven't controlled committee
meetings in the house and and by they I
mean Maga Republicans I mean the
trumpers the [__] q and honors
haven't controlled the committee
hearings ever until now yeah because
they're doing that it seems like
Democrats are having such an easy time
of knocking these things down like
tennis balls right but the why is
because it's so delusional it's such
[__] it's it's so [__] stupid it's
just the right size and stupid so much
and it looked so easy to do I mean what
we do here every day when we're doing it
here on the show if most people like oh
this looks so easy it kind of is I mean
they truly are the joke I mean they set
it up right I mean like yesterday I sent
you a clip and if we want to play it or
not it's of uh representative Anna Luna
and she decided to open her mouth and
try to get you get well trying to get
the Twitter execs on a gotcha
um which I think is hilarious
because she totally misrepresented and
doesn't understand
what the tool was that they were using
well let's let's play this one last and
then we'll go to that but let's play
this one last clip where Daniel Goldman
I don't know if anyone knows who Daniel
Goldman is but he was one of the
attorneys that questioned
um during some of the impeachment uh
hearings to get impeachment on Donald
Trump but this is him questioning
Charlie because now he's a congressman
people didn't know that um Goldman is a
congressman now here's him uh just watch
it's hilarious because the first
amendment protects someone from yelling
fire in a movie theater
well unfortunately that one is not yes
or no because that's become a mantra for
people it's the homes uh shank uh line
um walk back on all right homes and we
don't need a law class here
um
do not having it no no [__] he's like
shut the [__] up man I don't need I
don't need to hear this I don't need
this conjecture I don't need you going
on some long rant about something that
is totally irrelevant just answer the
[__] question okay right right well I
mean which all of you seem to totally be
unable to answer which is like you guys
don't understand what the First
Amendment right is and you don't
understand that what Donald Trump did
was a violation by going to a private
Company by their definition Yeah by
their definition and understand that Joe
Biden who won at the time when the
hunter Biden story came out he was not
the president he was not even elected
the election had not happened yet so to
say like oh it was Joe Biden's
government he's weaponizing the
government the guy was a private citizen
hanging out chilling running for office
wasn't elected yet didn't get elected I
mean by their terms he was hiding in a
basement he was like he was sleepy Joe
Biden hanging out in the basement which
is amazing how often Republicans can be
like sleepy Joe Budden no man he's
falling asleep he's in the basement in
his rocking chair and this and that it's
like man Joe Biden is very very astute
and and smart to be having this whole
operation he's damn good at being
diabolic he's damn good he's diabolical
he's either lazy or he's the he's like
the king of lazy right yeah
it's incredible this is the clip that
you were talking about with uh Luna
let's watch this and then you can tell
us why she's full of [__] Mr Roth
um have you committed communicated with
government officials ever on a platform
called jira
now
okay so tell us who Lena is first and
then tell us what the jiren that thing
is yeah yeah so Luna is a uh well I
don't know if you just if you saw the
news but Luna claims that Chu is Jewish
did you know that what Jewish a Jewish
person or Jewish here we go turns out
Anna Paulina Luna said her father was a
Messianic Jew and that she was Ashkenazi
heritage
however
her family says her father was Catholic
and her grandfather fought in the Nazi
army oh damn oh damn that is the
complete opposite of what she claimed
she pulled to George Santos oh man I
think humans even worse yeah
you see what I mean when I say George
Santos isn't an outlier yeah I know not
at all right he's not an outlier but she
she's you know she's a representative
and this is her moment she's using right
now to be like oh I got you oh yeah you
[__] right wing guys are gonna
[__] jerk off to this one so what's
this Tech word that she's using so what
is it cute
okay this is this is how it is and I'm
gonna talk on experience okay
which is the opposite of what she's
going to speak on okay
jira is a tool that's made by a company
called atlassian okay atlassian makes a
whole
whole spectrum of tools right for
project management design uh engineering
these are production tools yeah yeah so
you're like oh I want to make a Trello
board which is a company they acquired
it's like oh you can have cars you drop
them and you say what the status just
makes your work and organization work
just more efficient right right jira is
a ticketing system so if I worked at a
company and I said oh there's a bug in
production I want to flag this take a
screenshot put it in there assign it say
what the hierarchy the level of
importance is
boom and again so what you're saying is
is they create they create a document
digitally that that now that document
can be pulled out of a bucket for
someone else to take care of right
basically that's what it is so in other
words in other words you're the person
and an organization you can't fix this
problem you've found it so you create a
ticket or a document that says hey can
someone fix this who knows how to fix it
and then the person knows how to fix it
sees that document it's like oh okay
this is a problem we didn't know about
until Gabe Sanchez pointed it out on
General exactly and now they take it and
they fix it is that what you're saying
yeah okay exactly so it's a ticketing
system that can be used both internally
Yeah by employees to be like oh we got
to work on this ticket not only is there
a problem but also be like all right we
got these tickets for actual projects
like well we want to build a feature
right we can use jira to track that and
that's what Jerry is it's tracking
either a feature a product a story a a
bug wait wait because what you're saying
wait wait because what you're saying is
back to the idea of this document is to
track who started it why they started
and then who who actually performs tasks
on that document is that what you're
saying exactly it's not only a document
system to let someone know like a like a
sticky note on their desk but it also
tracks that sticky note from person to
person to person yeah exactly there is a
full log right uh a full log right not
like there's a missing visitor log right
with Trump but there's a full log that
you use both in engineering and design
and project management and product
management and everything between right
so the way that it works is uh because
I've used it almost at every company
I've been at
in the in the moment of what they're
talking about
a support request so when you go to
Twitter and you say I've got a I want to
flag this tweet or I got a problem with
this account or something like that
those get made into tickets okay those
tickets those support requests go
through jira and then jira and their
team that uh at Twitter will then go
through and say okay this is high
importance this is low importance this
is medium this goes out to that team
this goes up to that team oh this needs
to be rerouted because it went to the
wrong team and it's the right Post-it
notes on the right right the screenshots
and here's a video of reproducing the
problem or whatever it is that's what
she's talking about right now she's
talking about using this private tool
Cloud base tool jira that somebody would
say hey I'm flagging these tweets right
because they were uh
non-consensual new tweets let's say
right
not their Department maybe not their
Department maybe yeah not their
department but then they would go in and
that's where they would track it
but you can have these communications
via email if you're associated with them
too so if you were a third party you
could email and respond to it so let's
say that you were the person that
reported this ticket or made a support
request to Twitter
you would have back and forth
communication and it would be logged in
this ticket to show who it was and
typically it's done through email or if
you're internally it's done via the
actual jira tool like the app itself and
so what she's going to talk about is
she's going to say oh there were all
these other people that were involved
that had Communications right but what
she's so [__] dumb and that she
doesn't understand and tries to use as a
gotcha moment is that all of the other
organizations are people that are
feeding in third party outside of the
app
so they're adding they're adding context
to what's going on they're not
communicating inside the tool okay they
don't have any and even if they were
inside the tool
there's a thing called I don't know
permissions
and so if you're in the tool you have
permissions that would say oh you only
have visibility to this you could only
access this one thing you can't go out
and do these other things maybe a ticket
that was assigned to you right exactly
so if you're a third party for whatever
reason and you're brought in as FBI or
CIA or these other things that they are
talking about right you're only going to
see what they give you the permission to
see right you're only going to be able
to access and view
what you as a just a a participant can
see right you can't go out and look at
other people's tickets you can't go out
and look at other people's information
jira is a support ticketing system it's
essentially how they use it what I want
to know what I want to know is
is jira part of the system that controls
the Jewish space lasers or is it not
part of that system let's let's listen
it's a it's a well yeah we'll let her
finish and then we'll see let's see what
the Q100 says here
real quick answer we're on the clock
into the best of my recollection not
your recollection great have if you did
in the event communicate who would have
had access to this platform
that's the nature of my confusion okay
did you ever speak to government
officials on jira regarding taking down
social media posts
again not to the best of my recollection
can you explain to me why the federal
government would ever have interest in
communicating through jira mind you a
private Cloud Server with social media
companies without oversight to censor
American voices I want to let you know
that this is a violation of the First
Amendment and the federal government is
colluding with social media companies to
censor Americans Mr chairman I ask for
unanimous consent to submit these
Graphics into record and Mr Roth I'm
going to refresh your memory for you
okay first off I want to I want to point
out that she's saying that the
government the FBI was was breaking
First Amendment does American citizens
First Amendment rights keep Sanchez
remind me when who was in charge of the
executive branch doj and the FBI at the
time that she's going to make these
accusations that this was happening was
it Joe Biden because it feels like she's
gonna say that well I don't know Joe
Biden didn't become president until 2021
okay yeah so this was after January 20th
of 2021 is that right this
must have been
totally was Trump not totally was Trump
she she literally is saying she's trying
to do a gotcha moment on him like the
federal government was violating the
citizens rights okay if that's the case
then let's go to the administration that
was overseeing the violation of the
Americans First Amendment right by I
mean this is so dumb in this exercise
this is one thing that they really
didn't calculate when they went and made
these stupid [__] promises to these
Cuban honors out there who voted for him
when they were like yeah we're going to
have committees and we're going to hold
them all accountable that means you too
dummies that means you two who were in
charge where where was where was the
republicans in Congress where were they
at they it's not like there was no
Republican Congressman on the oversight
committee right where the [__] were they
when were they asking questions about
jira and Twitter and Twitter files
during hearings because let me let me be
really clear about and how our gov our
government works and what you electing a
congress person and them be sitting on
committees asking questions is so
important that's why it is so important
number one that they ask really smart
questions of really smart Witnesses
that's the first thing the second thing
is a congressperson can ask any [__]
question to any witness that they want
in any hearing that they are in when
they have their time they can ask any
[__] question at all a republican
could have in the moment knowing that
the federal government trumps federal
government was was violating the
American People's First Amendment right
which is not even close to what was
happening it's not even close to what
was happening
that they could have questioned in that
moment any witness they wanted with that
question at that time and they didn't
they're only questioning it now because
they made stupid promises to stupid
people to get stupid people elected to
our government and it's all real dumb is
there more to this clip than her just
being boneheaded no I mean like
basically she brings out a little board
and she's like long it's like four
minutes yeah I don't know we have to go
into it I mean this is pretty much the
the I can sum this up right now she
brings out a board and she's like look
here is jira and here are all these
people organizations that we're
communicating with them right
he's like well that's not exactly what
and then she's like okay and then she
continues and cuts them off right and
what you'll Roth is gonna say
is her an understanding of what jira is
is so fundamentally wrong and it's the
reason that I I wanted to bring it up
and just if anyone online says oh
they're jira and this and that and Luna
well you know you know what you know
what they're doing you know what she's
doing here and and I'm thinking about
this because you always have to look
through
the microscope of a projection yeah
remember remember in the January 6
select hearing when the the app signal
came up the app signal and
Communications I use that thing almost
every day right so think about think
about her projection in the Republican
party's projection through this jira as
only projection of them using an app
like signal to I don't know I don't know
maybe maybe Scott Perry that's why he
doesn't want the Department of Justice
to have the contents of his cell phone
I'm just saying that could be a possible
situation is because he doesn't want
some of his Communications I would
almost bet it's projection full on full
stop that's why she does it's not that
she doesn't understand jira oh yeah I
mean I could I could totally see her
trying to cover because here's the other
thing too she's trying to go after big
Tech and she's saying big Tech which is
you know it's a it's a uh I think at
last scene is a publicly traded company
now
but a lot of companies use them because
they're good at what they do it's a
private Cloud so you mean they're good
at communication and production tools is
that what you're saying yeah it's crazy
it's crazy it's crazy but also I
wouldn't be surprised if she tries to
use this as a way to be like oh jira
this and we got to go after jira and
you're a big Tech and blah blah blah
[__] and that's not at all what it
is it's not like social media they're
not coming after you you're not [__]
tracking you on the stuff it's used for
for business owners and management and
developers and and designers all so that
you can get the products that you use
like I don't know uh Twitter right and
here's the thing Twitter still uses jira
to track all of the tickets
whoa whoa whoa wait a second are you
telling me that Elon is colluding with
the cabal by using jira because no I
don't believe it's pronounced cabal it's
according to Margaret Taylor green it's
pronounced Cable cable okay now that's
she said there's a global seriously with
a Democrat Satan worshiping cable
Malik so like a huge long line that
stretches from Pole to pull because
that's a cable that's the case that's a
key that's a cable we are part of the
cable we are part of the line table to
pull okay our next bonehead of course um
he's never stopped being a bonehead ever
Jim I don't report sex crimes Jordan so
I I'm trying to look it up and I'm
trying to figure out which moment I'm
there's a lot of Jim Jordan bone-headed
moments this week
um there's there's a lot of them folks
uh the one that stood out to me though
was the one where Connolly follows up
after he questions
again Joe Roth is the um yeah I'm trying
to find that clip I actually I think I
retweeted it because we showed it the
other day let's show that one because
that's really the tone for the week yeah
um here and everything they started the
week off like that they were like oh
we're gonna get himself that was that
was like in the first hour yeah that
that happened yeah Connolly slam dunks
him and it's been nothing but that type
of Slam Dunk sense from the very
beginning Republicans on this committee
thought they had a [__] slam dunk
opportunity to be like look Twitter and
Biden and Jack Dorsey and all of these
Executives all colluded to stop
misinformation about the covid-19
vaccine that's not actually his
information about the election right
right I mean this thing the they're
saying that they colluded to stop all of
these things that they should have
stopped right and they did stop for the
most part which was like Russia who did
they collude with other than they're
like you know our plan we don't want our
platform to go down the [__] dumpster
right so let's not drive off all of our
really our our our intellectual users
and people who I don't know are Tethered
to reality right so that our [__]
platform doesn't become
a dumpster fire Republicans don't
understand or they don't or they're
rather they're unwilling to understand
you mean they don't know capitalism
which they claim to be is that what
you're saying I don't know understand
how capitalism works I'll say this based
on what Lauren bobert complained and
whined on the house floor that Newsmax
should be given a deal with DirecTV when
DirecTV a private company said you guys
have a hundred thousand viewers and the
government should force DirecTV to do
this yeah and not only that I think
Newsmax the deal was newsmaster's like
oh you should pay us the subscription
model from for people to watch much and
we should be allowed to be on there and
DirecTV was like you guys have literally
the lowest news uh viewership of all of
the new uh cable shows that we have it
sucks why would we ever give you that
response like why would we ever give
that it's not like your Fox News which
has like 20 million viewers well you
know the other reason why DirecTV was
not um likely to do a deal with Newsmax
is because Newsmax gives away their
entire network for free right that you
can literally and I did a video about
this
um what the [__] was his name he's a rep
Burleson I think was his name he stood
on the house floor and compared Newsmax
being kicked from DirecTV to the
Holocaust you remember that scumbag yeah
yeah and I made a video I was like look
man I understand that it's a real
inconvenience for you to download the
Newsmax app on your [__] cell phone
but leave the genocide of [__] six
million Jewish people out of it man
right what the [__] how are you you
comparing the inconvenience for you to
go and download an app on your phone to
the Holocaust give me a bucket you
winding up all the oppression right oh
I've got to download it because
literally Newsmax has an app where you
can watch their live coverage you can go
back and watch their shows for a certain
amount of time it's all free they don't
they give it away well I mean it's got
commercials on it yeah yeah but you can
you can watch it you can watch it on the
you know the fire stick you could watch
on your phone your iPad your computer
there are they're almost like countless
ways you could get access to Newsmax
one of them right it's just one of them
if you really wanted to again you get a
fire stick plug that [__] into the
computer or into the TV you get it and
boom you got it that could be the only
thing you watch if you want and that's
the difference between like Newsmax and
Fox News is Fox News does not do that
Fox News does not give away they have a
huge contract with these cable companies
and these and these satellite companies
where they get a certain percentage of
the subscription costs that's how boxing
make so much [__] money not off their
viewership is because they give it
they're giving them the rights to it
meaning they're selling they're selling
the syndication almost in such a way for
a percentage of their subscription
profit and they have the additional
things where like I got the
documentaries and the special program
and yes it is and well and they have Fox
News digital which is basically the
Newsmax of Fox News and it's the one
that's free it's the one that has all
the the B team on it right it's the one
that they can give away for free but
here's uh here's the Bonet Jim Jordan
having his uh news max moment or Fox
News moment whatever you want to call it
although they didn't play this one on
Newsmax or Fox News I'm sure of course
of course not this is what this is where
Connolly so clearly folds him up like a
lawn chair watch this is this a
violation of the first amendment when
the government Mr Chan again sending you
an email saying we think these accounts
need to be looked at because they
violate your terms of service that's a
different standard so you got the
government saying your the service which
don't have to comply with the First
Amendment but the government's saying we
don't think these accounts comply with
your terms of service please take them
down so what he said is just all lies
right there right wait did he just say
your terms of service you mean that a
private company established guidelines
and rules to which how you should be
able and how you uh really how you
should act on their platform
that they own so if you wanna if you
want to play in the sandbox then you
gotta follow our rules you can't throw
[__] out of the sandbox you can't take a
[__] in the sandbox you can't do all
these other things you don't eat the
sand just make your Sand Castle Play
with other people don't or go to another
platform where they let you [__] and if
you don't like it there then go to the
jungle gym with the kid that's licking
the poll I don't care right let's let's
do the end of this clip because it's
beautiful how Connolly picks him apart
here because Jim Jordan at this point
has been talking for like five minutes
saying all kinds of bullsh
and then I want to tell you how the
Republicans actually are setting
themselves up in in in the 119th to the
120th Congress to change a lot of this
terms of service and what we're talking
about
you see a problem there Mr Mr Roth
Mr chairman I'm seeing a flashing red
light I'm happy to answer the question
um
do I think that that's a valuable use of
the FBI's time no but I don't see in a
request for review a problem under the
First Amendment no I sure do I I thank
the gentleman I go back
chair recognized Mr Conley for five
minutes here we go thank you Mr chairman
my my my what happens when you hold a
hearing and you can't prove your point
[Laughter]
oh poor Jim I don't report sex crash I
mean they they really tried so hard
to figure out always try hard at their
life this is gonna be the moment we're
gonna own the [__] Libs and then and
then and then you know the Democrats on
the committee go okay cool we're going
to read through the information that you
also have been provided oh and look
we've revealed certain things like
Chrissy teigen's tweet and also the fact
that you know uh Donald Trump and the
White House tried to get it taken down
again a a government
institution influencing the
the outcome of a private Network and one
of its users a private citizen
but oh no no no we can't talk about we
can't talk about people reporting
questionable tweets especially ones that
are non-consensual nude photos which
anyone can report any tweet at any time
I would love
and actually I wouldn't love to see
these photos but I would love to see the
idea or hear the idea that let's say one
of these Republican Representatives they
get one of their photos released without
consent naked
the photo it was a [__] dick pic that
they sent to their someone hacked their
phone and they take the photos steal it
and then they say boom we're taking
these photos and we're putting them on
Twitter do you think can you honestly
tell me that anyone in their right mind
especially Republican representative who
had photos stolen from them and then
posted without their consent
that they wouldn't say oh uh uh yeah I'm
gonna report that that photo and that
tweet to be taken down
so it's it's one of those things where
Republicans want to whine and complain
about this I mean they're very thirsty
and very eager to just allow people to
share photos of Hunter Biden's dick
that's because that's that's the key
there it's only because it's Hunter
Biden that is it that's the only key is
because this is the only thing that they
have been able to to scrounge up in the
100 100 biting laptop story that gives
them the ability to have these committee
hearings because they can't they can't
show the evidence of the Lambda right
because it doesn't exist so the only
thing that they have is this obscure
link to the New York Post and these and
these posts on Twitter that were taken
down because it was non-consensual
nudity from Hunter Biden's huge ass dick
right I mean that that's literally the
only two points they have and those two
points really don't support their
narrative and I here's what I believe
I believe that what the Republicans are
doing in this moment of stupidity is
actually marching the country because
people like this is so [__] stupid
what a dumb exercise and really maybe
maybe the government and maybe the
Congress and maybe the American people
should have a little more oversight over
the terms of service of social media
companies especially since they're
they're supposed to be news to some
degree maybe they should have more say
and more oversight over their terms of
service maybe the government should be
saying hey if you're going to be
claiming and you're going to actually
participate in the social media space
you cannot allow someone to be spreading
something that is news that is not news
you cannot so I think actually what
they're doing in their attempt to to to
convince the country that because
Twitter wouldn't allow a link for one
day and they wouldn't allow Hunter
Biden's dicks dick picks to be shown on
Twitter that somehow that's how Joe
Biden stole the election is really it's
a far fair I mean we're talking even Q
anoner's gonna be like what are you
[__] me I mean I believe that JFK
Junior's alive but come on like really
this is this is the best you've got I
mean this is the collusion that they're
that they're trying to talk about I mean
yeah they they really really do try like
it's best family dog [__] it's dumber
than dog [__] it's so it's it is it is
so
so insane how hard and desperate that
they try to be like oh we're gonna get
him on this one and then they're like if
you guys would have read maybe the
second or third paragraph you would have
realized
that the guy that you worship also did
the things that you are mad about
Joe Biden supposedly doing which he
didn't do because he wasn't the
president
and it's every committee they're on this
one it's on the weaponization of the
federal government it's on anything
that's related to covid right because
this is Jim Jordan again this instance
of Jim Jordan he's not the chairman he's
the chairman of the weaponization not
the Twitter files committee he's just on
the committee so there's there's about I
don't know two dozen moments of Jim
Jordan's bone-headedry that we could
show just over the past two days so we
have to move on I apologize to not keep
showing Jim Jordan clips that you can
laugh at now and through the entire
weekend we must move on should I go to
the alpha clock or DM let's go the alpha
cut first why not let's go the alpha
[__] the alpha [__] is Rick Scott
he got Alpha cooked did you I I sent you
this clip I guess yeah yeah um and this
was this was I was like oh this has got
to be the alpha cook and it's only
because of this one clip it's not going
to take long to watch this thing because
he's he gets cucked so hard so fast
um it's hilarious to watch him now we
know the story from this week from the
state of the union when Joe Biden
basically painted the Republicans in
their own little corner where he was
like some of you
some of you want to destroy Social
Security and Medicare unofficially you
all want to unofficially but there's a
few of you that have written plans and
put them out there in the public that
indicates that you want to destroy
Social Security Medicare and not only
that some of you have spoken out loud
and it's been recorded that you want to
rip it up by its roots and get rid of it
all together quote unquote for Mike Lee
now they're really trying and basically
the moment in the State of Union is
where Joe Biden says you know what you
want to do this they were like oh you
lie and the petty Yeti was like Eli you
liar and that's going to be the moment
we're going to show later
but but when the penny Yeti does that
Joe Biden takes that opportunity to go
you know what you're right maybe I am a
liar maybe you do want to defend Social
Security Medicare they're like yay and
he's like so what we can do is take the
the
the the the the
existence of Medicare Social Security we
can put it back on the permanent table
we do not have to sunlight it we will
not get rid of it and you guys are gonna
now defend it they're like yay and then
afterwards they're like what the hell
did we just do because now not only not
only did they do it in the moment they
continued to go around saying no the
plans that were to break up Social
Security and get rid of Social Security
Medicare and get rid of earned benefits
because they're not entitlements they're
earned benefits from Americans that's
that was never in our plan even though
it's right there it's never in our plan
and you're lying if it's in our plan we
know because we wrote it in our plan but
we don't want to say it's in our let me
just give you the clip let me just give
you the clip here here is um it's on CNN
which I don't play a lot of CNN clips
and here is Rick Scott
and he he literally he's literally using
Jake Tapper
the fake news CNN worst host ever as his
evidence of why it isn't in his plan but
this again women should be in charge of
everything she picks him apart
beautifully watch
you say he's twisting your words but he
said quote some Republicans want Social
Security and Medicare to Sunset you
wrote I suggest the following all
federal legislation sunsets in five
years if a law is worth keeping Congress
can pass it again
you were Republican Medicare and Social
Security are federal legislation and you
said if it's worth keeping Congress can
pass it again but but no one I don't
think has confidence that if something
comes up for a vote every five years
that Congress is going to be able to
make sure it stays especially something
that vitally important to so many
Caleb I've been clear I'm not going to
do it in contrast let's remember just
what a few months ago all Democrats
voted in Joe Biden signed a bill to cut
280 billion dollars out of mid-year 280
billion dollars cut out of Medicare okay
so he he does the whole what about ISM
right he's like oh I'll get her I'll
[__] get her here she may have
evidence that I want to kill Social
Security Medicare for all Americans and
earn benefits but I'm gonna show how Joe
Biden and the Democrats want to do the
same thing what about this [__] listen
to what she says
that's not true Senator we talked about
this the other day
passing the inflation reduction act
reducing drug spending is not cutting
benefits to Medicare okay so exactly
what she's saying so the program they're
talking about is that in the inflation
reduction act basically the federal
government says hey you know those drugs
the prescription drugs that you give our
seniors on Medicare we're gonna tell you
how much you can sell them for because
we know your profits [__] and you can
only sell them for this much and because
of that the federal government is going
to um let's see spend less money in
Medicare for those drugs we're not
reducing benefits it's reducing costs
for us the American people were saving
tax dollars by telling these drug
companies you can't make abnormal
profits you have to stay within a normal
margin of profit for these prescription
drugs that you're selling to Medicare
that is all that happened all that
happened is in instead of paying 300
hours for insulin the federal government
says no [__] you can't charge us 300
you can only charge us 35. that's it
that's all that happened we are spending
less money of our tax dollars so when
Rick Scott says this what he's actually
saying is I hate when the American
people save money on their tax dollars I
hate it I hate it I hate it but let's
let's continue because he just can't let
it go
okay okay let me just read you something
Jake Tapper said
when uh Republicans proposing reducing
since when did Republicans listen to
what the [__] even I don't listen to
what he brought this thinking oh this is
the moment I'm gonna get it because he's
on CNN he's like wait where's Jake I
thought Jake was gonna be interviewed
right like what the [__] wait one more
one does even anyone ever like really
who's a normal person take Jake Tapper
that seriously like I don't even show
Jake Tapper in clips that often yeah I
don't even know that I had the last
couple Clips I've seen of Jake Tapper
he's been on assignment on location so
CNN he's taken seriously yeah but also
both times that I watched him he was
laughing at the most recent and two
different occasions laughing at the most
recent development of the George Santos
lies he laughed I forgot what it was
recently
uh oh this is in your Santos research
that you found these yeah yeah like I
was looking at clips and they're like
and now Jake Tapper and then he just
goes and then he just starts laughing on
on air can't help it can't help it it's
just one of those things it's so
ridiculous you can't not laugh well Rick
stock Rick Scott gets even more
ridiculous here and she is sure to point
it out watch the cost of Medicaid he
said Jake Tapper said I know the Trump
Administration is excited that Medicaid
will go back to the stage where they
have more control and can experiment and
be more efficient but without question
880 billion dollars is a cut so it's a
is it a cut
when we when Republicans do it but not a
cut when Democrats propose well you're
referencing Senator I looked into this
because we talked about it the other day
and even again Spanky we've talked about
this I brought these facts out and now
we're going to do this again how stupid
are you but let's do it the senior VP
for aarp's government Affairs said this
has been fact checked repeatedly and
shown to be a lie in fact this bill
saves Medicare nearly 300 billion
dollars by lowering the price of drugs
300 how many billion How many how much
was that that was a lot of money what is
Medicare who is Medicare who is who has
this who is yeah who has this money
right this is so this is such a dumb
exercise yes they are cutting they're
cutting costs cost is the key word their
Rick Scott costs I know I know on
whatever Planet you're from that you've
come here to live in your your skin suit
that you're not a human but but God damn
on this planet cost has a [__]
meaning to the word it's it's so
ridiculous that because Democrats save
the federal government money that all of
a sudden now oh they're cutting benefits
no they're getting the same goddamn
benefit it's cheaper because Democrats
went well that's really dumb to overpay
and Joe Biden went that's really dumb to
overpay it's really stupid and we also
have to remember that four years the
four years that Trump was in office he
proposed cuts to both Medicare and
Social Security every single year you
mean cuts to benefits is what you're
saying yeah oh wow wow the thing that
Republicans say no no we don't want to
do that we we don't we don't want to we
don't want to take those benefits away
yes you do yes you do if anything you
guys want to privatize it so that you
can get some third-party company to come
in you know because free market
capitalism you want them to come in and
fight it or not not fight it but you
want them to to
have a profit margin and not only that
to have the people that you want to
operate it that as part of the donor
class for your [__] Pockets let's
listen let's listen to the final moments
where she really [__] him hard our Drug
Company only drug companies would say
that saving people money is a bad thing
but what about what Jake Tapper said
but what about literally what about him
but what about
he was referring to a reduction in costs
of Medicaid he was referring to a
reduction of cost in Medicaid exactly
Rick Scott your words right out of your
mouth you [__] bonehead a reduction
of cost in Medicaid you just can't make
this [__] up with these fools now let's
go to our dishonorable mention of the
week where we're going to reveal are not
reveal we're going to go over another
revelation of this Saga that is George
Santos not to be confused by Anthony
devolder or Ron Des Santos yeah you mean
Ron De Santos yeah
sure right there's so many aliens
Anthony zabrovsky you know but only for
Jewish people because supposedly
according to him Jewish people are who
give more money well and he's Jewish
apparently let's not forget that so what
is what is this story here that um so
you're gonna send me a link or a video
or something uh I don't have a link or a
video well okay I can I can
pull it up so basically I'll set the
stage for you
um I was doing some digging uh into
George Santos and there was a uh there
was a
a there was a court record
or a charge
on on George Santos's uh background
check right so a few weeks ago came
across this through a friend who was
helping me do some uh some digging and
they were like
um
uh basically there was a charge in
Pennsylvania in York Pennsylvania now if
people don't know what where York
Pennsylvania is it's a very small it's
Amish Country it's like two to three
thousand people population wise
and I kept trying to figure out like
what the hell is going on like what is
this charge from because I can't figure
out what's going on because the way that
it was described and I'll try to find a
tweet here but basically the way that it
was described is it was um
uh uh there was a crime that he was
charged with back in November on
November 13 2017.
in in York Pennsylvania which is like
that's so weird he lives in New York why
would he be in Pennsylvania especially
in some like Amish country area
so as I'm trying to look for it I can't
find I'm looking up the docket number
I'm looking up the case you know the
court number all this stuff I cannot
find what's going on
only to realize that there's this
reporter that I've been in contact with
since uh since one some of the early
um Santo stories dropped Jacqueline
sweet she sent me the link yesterday
because she's now over at Politico she
used to be a patch and she was the one
who broke the story on the veterans uh
the veterans GoFundMe dog that he stole
the three thousand dollars well now
she's at Politico and she shared the
story with me that she broke yesterday
which basically she figured out what
happened only because
she was able to get in contact with a
lawyer slash old classmate friend that
George Santos had hired her to help with
and the reason that she's able to speak
about what the contents of the
kind of the case was is because it was
expunged so no one could look it up
that's why I wasn't able to find it in
the court system and any court record
that wasn't able to find anywhere
because they wiped it because they
expunged it they wiped it in
Pennsylvania not even not even uh I
believe that authorities like police
can't even find it once it's been
expunged different rules in different
states like expunge stuff can also be
like exhumed right but in some states
expunged is like it's done it's gone and
in Pennsylvania it never existed yeah it
completely gone however in the
background check it still showed up
because as of 2021 it was still on his
record that he had this crime but he got
it expunge in 2021 through the help of
this uh this former classmate friend
that he ran into at a Starbucks in 2019.
and so in 2020 he was like so what wait
what so you're just like you're going to
get a mocha tall latte or whatever the
hell it is I don't know yeah you know he
goes to start he's like hey man can you
help me expunge this crime I mean what
happened what happened was he ran into
her you know I don't know what name he
used when he made the order like it was
Anthony or George or Santos or devolder
or zabrovsky or Katara whatever it was
he put it on there ran into her had a
conversation and then he was served
extradition
to Pennsylvania for the crime by the
police which even then during this this
coffee shop
sorry I thought you meant like he's
sitting in the coffee shop and they walk
in like hey buddy and and the friend's
like whoa wait a second I can get him
expunged this is this this story I would
bet that's how Anthony devolder would
tell the story though that's probably
how he would tell the story and so what
happened is in 2020 they served him with
this and then he was like ah and he
reached out to this woman and was like
hey I need your help and then she
explained what happened and
this is the story of of how this all
laid out in 2017 George Santos goes to
Amish Country
uh pays for these dogs these these it's
a puppy mill okay let's just call what
it is they were breeders it's a puppy
mill
they in the Amish community in the Amish
community I mean also I didn't know this
but I looked this up uh yesterday and I
found out that the Amish community is
not
not uh nice or kind to animals like
they're very kind of [__] up about it
anyway so they have this puppy mill and
he pays two separate he pays two
separate checks
he dates them
after his visit to Amish Country so he
dates them November 13th and then he
dates them November 25th or 20 22nd
sorry 22nd
then he goes to New York right and then
in New York there's an adoption event
that he holds that he hosts on November
20th
and then he hosts another one on the
25th and they host another one later on
later on later on
these checks are dated for this time but
what ends up happening is George Santos
contacts his bank and says my checkbook
was stolen I don't have my checks
they're not my checks
but it's very suspicious because the
dogs
that he picked up from the dog breeder
puppy mill an Amish country were the
dogs that he just happened to [__]
stumble upon in the street and say oh
there was a pregnant mother and I got
this litter of of Golden Retrievers
which is like the fact that you can find
puppies
just like randomly or you find a mother
that has a litter of puppies is so rare
right people are always like I want a
puppy I want a puppy I want a puppy but
when it comes to actually finding dogs
to take to a rescue they're typically
older right they're a year two years
three years five years old or whatever
finding a litter of puppies or getting
access to a litter puppies that you just
stumble upon is so uncommon
so rare especially that's because
everyone that's because everyone wants a
puppy and then it turns into a dog right
and that's why they end up being rescued
because people like oh the puppy's cute
and then like oh I have a dog and it's
[__] everywhere well now I gotta get
rid of the dog I wanted a puppy now I
got a dog and so and so basically how it
played out was he wrote these checks and
then these Amish breeders were like cool
and they went to go cash the checks and
then they're like oh the checks bounced
so now
he just defraud like he just defrauded
these Amish puppy mill Farmers by giving
them bounce checks that he canceled like
intentionally canceled wrote on the
Czech memos puppies or puppy
when they went to go check with cash it
it bounced they put out basically like
all right we're gonna charge this guy
but where is he we don't know where he
is or who he is
he's in New York and then it wasn't
until 2020 did they finally find him
when they came to his door with papers
to be like hey there's this crime we
need to extradite you back to
Pennsylvania this guy has actually had
crimes even though they've been expunged
which now we can say had yeah and they
had to be expunged or were expunged he's
had crimes around these the the the
puppy scheme listen I'm not saying that
only a republican could look at puppies
and go you know what I bet this would be
a great this would be a great gift but
I'm saying that only only Republicans
could look at puppies and go you know
what this would be a great grift right
um and this is only this and this is
just a this is a a screenshot of one of
the Articles uh that covered it but
basically talked about how he we had
this you know this Pet Rescue this fake
charity he had an adoption event with
pet Oasis uh he showed up with these
golden retrievers these uh little uh
Terriers uh uh German Shepherds all
these other dogs golden retrievers all
this stuff and here's another one is he
told so in here he said Staten Island
resident Michelle vazo said that she
adopted an English cream golden
retriever at one of fopu's pet Oasis
events that year in 2017 in uh December
I believe or uh end of November
and she said the the amount was 300 to
400. but these this is where Santos
tells like a kernel of Truth wrapped in
a big [__] corn of lye okay the the
kernel of Truth is that they came from
an Amish puppy mill the LIE is that he
bought them okay you can't rescue them
he paid a breeder to be like hey I want
these dogs give me the litter of dogs
and I'll pay you this amount of money
that way I can go grift other money
exactly that they're puppy milk because
what he's doing essentially is what
you're saying is he's going to a puppy
mill instead of trying to I don't know
fix the problem of the puppy mill he's
like contributing to the problem of the
puppy mill like hey I'm gonna pay you
money for these puppy mill dogs and then
he's gonna go to another state he
crosses the state line he's like hey I
need you to help me raise money because
I got these puppy mill dogs that I
rescued even though I actually bought
them rescued
right and it's and it would be totally
different right if if George Santos
wanted to make the argument hey guys I I
I I stole these dogs because I was
saving them right I I just it doesn't
work it doesn't work I just realized
something
he literally is going to people and and
I don't know why I didn't it didn't just
click there just now he's going to
people and saying hey help me raise
money
for for this to rescue these dogs out of
the puppy mill and what these people
don't know is they're giving money for
him to go back to Pennsylvania and buy
more puppies out of the puppy mill to
keep them in business
right because the checks the checks were
out and then he's bouncing the Jets he's
not even actually buying them here's
here here's the thing so he's still
standing by him he stole the dogs from
the puppy mill and if people want to be
like oh well you know or George Sanders
are like oh well guys okay yes that was
me I'm now admitting to the crime that I
said it wasn't actually me my checks
were stolen so I wasn't actually an
Amish country and I'm sure if you showed
these Farmers this photo they'd be like
yeah that's the [__] dick that stole
the dog
but I think when if you look at this
George Santos could possibly try to make
the argument okay you know what it
actually was me or he tries to say well
if somebody but I stole them from a
puppy mill that I was doing a service
but it would only work if George Santos
then say Oh look I stole these from the
puppy mill to free them and rescue them
and then give them to a rescue what he
did was no no no I'm now going to
partner with this pet Oasis Pet Shop and
I'm gonna have a pet adoption event
every single Saturday from November into
December and I'm gonna make people pay
300 to 400 for these dogs which means
probably we need probably may have paid
50 bucks for him I don't know how much I
mean I don't well I don't know how many
he got out of each litter one of them
was 775. so even if he sold he may have
been getting a discount because he was
buying more than one and another one was
1100 so I don't know how many dogs he
got out of each litter for each check
that he wrote but I can tell you that
even within two or three dogs he's made
his money back well let's just say this
not only is it he's the dishonorable
mention this week he's a [__] scumbag
oh yeah and you know there's more I've
I'm working on more in addition to the
one story I I broke earlier stay tuned
I'm sure there's going to be more Santos
lies especially around puppies that are
gonna be brought out and you're gonna go
wow he really is a republican
um speaking speaking a dumb bone-headed
Republicans
so we had Jim I don't report sex crimes
Jordan Jonathan Turley
and then representative Marjorie Taylor
green Otherwise Known here on the Tony
Michaels podcast now and forever as the
petty Yeti and that is the moment that I
think we're going to show here why I
mean there's a lot of reasons again like
Jim Jordan and the Turley uh why they
were boneheaded this week like we could
we could do four hours just on these
three Margaret Taylor green you know
last week she had her five billion
dollar to an elementary school moment
this week she also had another uh
uh Twitter files moment but it was the
state of the union that really just like
really kind of cemented her position in
the running this week right and this
really gives us with this uh bone-ended
moment during the State of the Union
um this road can you uh let's see what's
the I want I think Patriot takes has
that full clip of the moment well while
Joe Biden yeah here it is I got it okay
so
um this is from the Patriot takes
account pulled it this is from the Fox
News uh report of the state of the union
now you see Lauren bobert which we're
not short on boneheads here in this clip
but there's one I want you to focus on
and I'll show it to you uh when the
petty Eddie stands up and calls Joe
Biden a liar and this is the moment
where
heat traps as Rick Scott is trying to do
damage control he traps Republicans
into agreeing with him not to put
Medicare and Social Security earn
benefits that Americans earn while
they're working not to put them on the
chopping block let's watch taking the
wealthy pay their fair share some
Republicans some Republicans want
Medicare and Social Security Sunset I'm
not saying it's a majority
let me give you anybody who doubts it
contact my office I'll give you you can
you can you can come to my office after
hours right right and discuss it right
right you get just just call call My
People your people call my people and
we'll talk about what you do and don't
believe in the [__] you say and the
bills that you write and the suggestions
that you make in writing ron Johnson and
and and this Rick Scott and Mike Lee
saying at
[__] campaign events I want to rip
Social Security Medicare up by their
roots and get rid of them all together I
mean it's kind of you're not even
beating around the bush that you're
ripping up by the roots at that point
Mike Lee but this here this screenshot
here is of Marjorie Taylor green
formerly known as Marjorie Hood foot
green now otherwise known as the petty
Yeti here on the Johnny Michaels podcast
um you can see the coat that she was
wearing now
um there's a couple different things in
this clip that I want to give context to
because leading up to the State of the
Union the bonehead uh dressed up as
Pennywise Otherwise Known here Petty
wise and walked around the capitol with
a balloon and gave photo ops and did
some stupid stuff
that kind of fell on its face so then
she decided to wear this coat with fur
on it or obviously she was trying to
have social media moments but in this
moment she doesn't know it but what she
is doing is she's only providing a way
for Joe Biden to trap them into agreeing
in front of the entire American people
on National live television that they
will not get rid and rip up Social
Security Medicare an earned benefit of
working Americans buy the roots and get
rid of it watch this and she calls him a
liar and you can see her the pettyeli
yelling and screaming and and I don't
know whatever you want to screeching
whatever you want to call it I'll give
you a copy I'll give you a copy of The
Proposal
[Applause]
that means Congress doesn't vote
well I'm glad liar the petty Yeti says
now there's a lot of screenshots there's
a lot of pictures of this moment going
around the internet of the petty Eddie
doing this and it will forever be memed
um well at least for a long time as long
as we have to put up with the petty Yeti
herself which
um if it's if as long as the pipe bomb
investigation doesn't come to fruition
it may be a while I'm just saying I'm
not saying those two stories the pipe
bomber on January 6th has anything to do
with the petty Eddy story but I am
saying that they kind of seem to say I
mean Karma does take a minute right it's
a [__] it's a [__] it takes a minute
to get there but when it comes right I
mean Jack Smith is laying Karma down on
Mike Pence Yesterday by subpoena him uh
to the the grand jury of the special
counsel but let's finish this clip
because I think it's significant in her
bone editory of how Biden turns her
absolute [__] fit her Karen fit her
Petty Eddie Karen fit into a win for the
American people watch this see and I'll
tell you I enjoy conversion
you know amazing
if Congress doesn't keep the programs
the way they are they'd go away other
Republicans say I'm not saying it's a
majority of you I don't even think it's
even a significant
but it's being proposed by individuals
they just keep digging in that's kind of
their thing just keep moving we never
said
it's like okay we have laptop laptop
laptop
saying that exact same thing or quotes
direct quotes or direct plans written
like in ink and stuff
I'm not politely not naming them but
it's being proposed by some of you
look
folks
the ideas
that we're not going to be we're not
going to be moved into being threatened
to default on the debt if we don't
respond
folks
and there's Mike Lee oh what what why
won't you name me because I'm the one
who said it yeah
[Applause]
so folks
as we all apparently agree
Social Security Medicare is also off the
books now right got him got him and and
that's the moment that's the moment
where all the Republicans like yeah
yeah what what did we do oh wait hold on
what did we just agree to we did we just
did we just say that we would not pull
Social Security Medicare up by his roots
and get rid of it God damn it you got us
again [__] Uncle Joe a goddamn son of
a like sleepy Joe Biden guys an evil
genius
he's he cognitively impaired and he
can't think he doesn't know where he's
going and he needs everyone so he can
think on his feet but boy that guy can
think it reminds me it reminds me uh
whoever wrote that part of the speech I
mean Bravo
um it reminds me
um
or if he actually just like kind of
winged that moment like it was off the
cuff but it does remind me those moments
when you catch someone where you're like
do you agree then like yeah you know and
like they're like yeah and their
agreement and then you say something
obviously that would catch him like yeah
wait no oh [__] no I didn't mean that
you know and it's that moment where they
get he gets them going right and they
don't realize where it's gonna be he's
like all right great I I'm I'm uh I'm
super happy that we all agree that uh
this is important we should save it and
like oh well because it's it's only it's
it's like a Jedi mind trick but not
really because they are going to
disagree with him every time like Joe
Biden could yeah dark Brandon Rick Rick
from YouTube says dark Brandon Joe Biden
could come out tomorrow and say uh I
think abortion should be abolished all
across the land in every state there is
no exception they'd be like whoa no you
have to have exception like yeah they
because they have to disagree they can't
agree they have to disagree there's
that's their per own the libs is their
personality now rather Joe Biden
intended to do this to them or not I
actually believe that I don't think it
was the actual intent I knew that he
could take advantage of these moments
and here's why we talked about it
earlier here in the week on the show Joe
but because the one thing they try to
say to Joe Biden oh he's a career
politician and he's been in politics
forever like that's one of the best
things about him like if you really want
to if you really want to talk about what
gave Joe Biden the chops to do this to
the Republicans it was because he knows
exactly the situation in that moment and
he knows exactly the opportunity that he
can take in that moment and he did he
took the opportunity to basically paint
them in this corner where now they're
going on [__] mainstream media the
lame stream meeting as they call it and
trying to explain away why they wanted
to get rid of Social Security Medicare
it was it was it's not what you think
okay right it's not what you think I
didn't want to take it away for this
reason right which makes it even worse
they're making it even worse for
themselves which I applaud and I think
these boneheads should keep going so
congratulations to Marjorie Taylor green
for standing up and making such a hoopla
during that moment and giving Joe Biden
the opportunity to wad you [__]
up and dunk you in the trash so let's
give her her do
[Music]
[Applause]
oh thank you petty Yeti I want to remind
everybody bonehead of the week is every
single Friday on the Tony Michaels
podcast we post a clip on Midas Touch
channel so subscribe there also
subscribe to the Tony Michaels podcast
you get to vote every single week you
vote you decide who's the owner of the
week just go to the community tab on the
Tony Michaels podcast YouTube channel or
you can follow us on Twitter at Tony
Michaels pod the poll is there as well
and we count all the votes we do not
stop the steal here we count all the
votes on Twitter and on YouTube so make
sure to vote every single week
and we do this on Friday every single
Friday in the second hour well now kind
of the third hour or something yeah
almost and today was a little long yeah
well you know we had the George Santos
stories that we had to go through so
make sure to download every single
episode because you don't want to miss
these George Santos uh stories on the
Tony Michaels podcast on Apple Spotify
and Google every single weekday Monday
through Friday two full hours
every single weekday everyone if you're
listening live stick around we have a
few announcements
that's been bonehead of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
bonehead of the week
it's a good segment it's good segment we
have a few announcements uh Gabe I want
you to talk about uh your patreon real
quick and remind the audience again of
what will happen over the weekend and
yeah
I think the plan is Sunday I'm going to
uh to actually launch the patreon so
it'll allow you I mean I'm giving you
behind the scenes kind of you know
idea of what goes on in this creative
space where I'm you know in this we're
gonna get are we gonna so we're gonna
actually get behind the scenes look of
how you actually do it yeah so I'll give
you you know yeah that's working hard or
hardly working whichever one you think
you know I'll be so you actually get to
see the green screen as a green screen
and realize that you're not actually
exactly there's no window there it's not
a bridge no window There's No Illusion
it's all like some prison or something
are you a Republican or something that
you're I mean it's just a mirage it's
one of those things but it's uh yeah
you'll you'll get behind the scenes kind
of footage and and photos and I'll share
you know you know what I I'm making
suggestions here but you know what else
you should do is because I know a lot of
times like you'll send me stuff and
you're like hey should I use this one or
this one yeah you should do that on your
patreon should I use this one or or get
or say here were the two choices and
here's the one right show them that kind
of behind the scenes stuff I'm just
making suggestions so there's you know
there are there are always jokes that I
I write I'm like ah you know and then
and I film and I'm like then it doesn't
really flow so we're gonna get bloopers
so maybe there there could be bloopers
behind the scenes stuff I'm thinking of
doing like a green room q a like so
after the show or after the the episode
airs later in the day uh I'll have you
know people who pay whatever tier oh so
they can come in and ask you a question
about that yeah they ask questions you
know for talk about it and like I've got
different ones that the naming of them
is audience member staff writer segment
producer and then if you really want to
show your love there's executive
producer where you'll get your name on
there we go one-on-one calls every month
you know stuff like that so well there's
a lot of a lot of fun stuff that I have
planned this sounds like exactly up our
audiences Ally so everyone be watching
for that next week uh for the launch and
um also be watching uh speaking on
patreon watch my patreon this week and
I'm going to do a uh a rant on Missouri
voted on a law to let children carry
around Firearms uh yeah any age you know
six-year-olds running around town with
AR-15s what could go wrong they that
every single Republican almost every
single Republican in Missouri voted for
this um this is only this is only
um a tale to come and what I mean by
that is other states are going to follow
suit because they're going to find this
to be really good politics in their
crazy Q Anon circles
um and it's because it because it's
going to piss off the Liberals like no
it just pisses off people that you're
gonna that you're gonna do the stupid
thing of just making it legal for
six-year-olds to carry around AR-15s on
the [__] sidewalks and [__] I mean
they can't they can't go to a PG-13
movie or a rated R movie they sure as
hell can carry around an assault weapon
it's so stupid so messed up it's it's
ridiculous but that that is the
Republican party in which we have to
deal with so I'm gonna deal with it uh
this weekend so be watching that it'll
probably be on Sunday on patreon so if
you're interested go to
thetonymichaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com you'll find my patreon link
there and again don't don't
um you're gonna be watching for Gabe's
patreon uh link as well on his link tree
uh if you're not already
subscribe to the YouTube channel now I
want to thank everyone this week we got
the 14 000. on our road to 20 14
000 subscribers officially on our road
to 20 000 so thank you very much also
follow us on Twitter at Tony Michaels
pod where you can vote for bone of the
week and download every single episode
Monday through Friday
um on Apple Spotify Google after I get
the show done that's when I edit the
audio version and I put it up on all the
podcast directories so whichever podcast
director that you listen to it on and if
you're not go listen to it why not why
not you might learn something twice
um so go listen to it on your favorite
directory but give us a great review
there and subscribe on your favorite
directory also if you're on Facebook
follow us at the Tony Michaels and you
can watch it on YouTube live here on our
Channel but also the upwire.com go to
upwire.com and go to their YouTube
channel and watch it as well one other
thing on Twitch I'm learning twitch I'm
learning how it works here's the thing
so twitch if you log in with your Prime
account you get a free subscription
where there's no commercials so if
you're watching over on Twitch and
getting commercials just log in with
your Prime account you won't have any
commercials there's no commercials if
you log in with your Prime and even if
you don't watch on Twitch but you have a
Prime account you can give me your free
subscription then cost you a thing to
give me your free subscription on Twitch
helps out the show so go over on Twitch
log in with your Prime account and give
us the free subscription if you can and
you know watch next week every single
weekday like you did this week Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central
now three hours on Friday
um we have a long ways so
I think we should end it everyone have a
great weekend
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon